so da bin ich muss aber schnell mein headset entwirren erinnert sich niemand
an mein video ich habe headset lohnen sich nicht da kriege ich heute immer
noch kommentare wo die leute sagen max sauerei wie kannst du so ein video
machen und du hast selber ein headset die abo oder schon besser gesagt des
abo headsets sind halt kacke headsets sind vor allem eins in der regel viel zu
teuer was ich halte dass nicht ein paar gute gibt und es ist auch besser
geworden mittlerweile ja die meisten headsets vor allem gaming headsets und
vor allem wenn sie rgb haben sind meistens voll für den arsch leute
soll ich es riskieren ob ich die bitrate ein bisschen hoch machen kann
was meint ihr macht er heute vodafone mit was riskieren
ja komm das hatten wir gestern noch schon das ist nicht overworld das hat
man gestern habe ich mir gestern schon darüber aufgeregt dass es nicht das
overworld theme ist so output probieren wir mal 3,9 wir sind mal wir sind
wir geben mal noch nicht alles mal gucken was ob vodafone heute mitmacht
scheinen zu funktionieren aber wartet mal bis die leute heute am abend wieder
alle im internet sind dann ist das nicht mehr so
moment es gab ein professor leighton und und dings hier phoenix ride crossover
gar nicht so sagt jetzt passt wunderbar lautstärke gut ich bin ein bisschen
bisschen müde wo soll ich gleich sagen ich bin heute irgendwie ein bisschen müde
das liegt daran dass heute acht stunden frontal-beschallung richtig
resident sleeper ich hatte acht stunden frontalbeschallung microsoft es war
schulung ist war echt langweilig es war besser als die letzte aber es war
trotzdem noch ganz schön langweilig acht stunden am stück max pracht der hansen
schreibt max
mir was max brachte mir einst von vor vielen vielen jahren bei mir niemals ein
headset sondern einen guten kopfhörer ein billiges clip on mikro zu kaufen also
mit dem billigen kopfhörer oder besser gesagt günstige kopfhörer fährst auf
jeden fall besser clip on mikros kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten aber die
kombination ist auf jeden fall rein von der audioqualität für dich deutlich
besser willst du mit meiner projektmanagement vorlesungen das ist
bwl zeug nein das will ich ganz bestimmt nicht
oh das war die riesen taschenlampe habe ich jemanden habe ich habe ich denn
meinen ppega board aktuell microsoft header klopps funktioniert nicht das von
gestern hat hat mich heute schon mal einer erwähnt im chat
ne bis jetzt noch nicht ja da kann ich auch nicht wissen ob funktioniert heute
wird heute ist der heute die shopping queen ist auch der shopping keks ist
angesagt ja funktioniert
funktioniert sehr schön
es hat euch alle mühe gegeben das zu schreiben jetzt löscht wie findest du
eigentlich opera gx wir haben so mal kurz angeguckt hat mich jetzt nicht
sonderlich beeindruckt ist das halt ein chrome nicht kaum wie heißt blink oder
chromium halt basierter browser der irgendwie nichts besser kann als alle
anderen auch weiß ich weiß gar nicht was man an der sache toll also war was da
dran so gut sein soll
die tasche lampe könnte man durch was anderes ersetzen
meint本 für sich eine salami
das könnte man machen ja die erscheint mir trotzdem etwas unrealistisch groß
kann die microsoft laut irgendwas was alle anderen clouds nicht können oder
hat das ding wie viele glaubte und keine da sah ans berechnung
er ist es mit die beste klaus gibt also keine da seien berechtigung kann man
nicht haben kann man nicht sagen kaufst du auch bei which ein nein da habe ich
mich bisher immer vorgedrückt.
Die Sache ist die, eigentlich müsste
ich es mal machen, weil
das war es
für mich. Das brauche ich. Das brauche ich.
Nein, nicht weg.
Einmalige Chance,
dass sie jetzt Instant abnehmen verpasst.
RIP.
Wieso ist die Microsoft Cloud die beste?
Naja, das nimmt sich...
Der beste war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Das nimmt sich jetzt nicht so viel.
Ich finde die Kombination bei Azure ganz gut.
Und was es für Standorte gibt...
Ja...
Ich kann es hier gar nicht so genau sagen.
Das ist halt eines der wenigen Sachen, womit ich
ein bisschen Erfahrung habe.
Ich habe bisher nur Amazon...
Nicht Amazon, Google Cloud
und Azure verwendet.
Und Azure fand ich auch, wenn Azure übelst unübersichtlich ist
und Microsoft teilweise selbst nicht weiß,
wie er ihre Sachen benennt,
noch eine ganze Ecke
angenehmer als die Google-Geschichte.
Preislich ist das Kram halt alles schweineteuer.
Aber dafür
sparst du dir halt alles andere.
Und musst dich selbst um nichts kümmern.
Gerade Kupernet,
das in Azure soll wohl ziemlich gut sein
im Vergleich zu den anderen Plattformen,
kann ich aber nichts zu sagen,
weil ich das persönlich in Azure noch nie verwendet habe.
Oh, da ist wieder Abnehmen.
Warum muss man sich da eigentlich annehmen?
Anmelden?
Was ist das?
Was macht der Typ da?
Das sind irgendwelche
Haken, die sich da nicht annehmen.
Nein, dann melden wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Wir kaufen jetzt ein, Leute.
Und heute kaufen wir wirklich ein.
Den Kram haben wir alles zu.
Meine Heizung müssen wir uns heute auch nicht angucken.
Octopi müssen wir uns heute auch nicht angucken.
AliExpress-Startseite.
Aller Banggood-Startseite.
Bam, bam, bam.
Banggood.
Bisschen kleiner machen, das Ganze.
Wer auch immer sich da in Indien oder China,
wo genau Banggood herkommt, gedacht hat,
dass Banggood ein guter Name ist,
weiß ich auch nicht.
Latenz zum Broadcaster.
0,87.
Boah, krasser Shit.
Ja, das wird wahrscheinlich gleich dadurch zunichte gemacht,
dass Vodafone wieder rumspackt.
Aber ich war noch mal klein,
die Musik ein Ticken leiser.
Jetzt war ich ein bisschen zu leise.
Ah, excellent.
Sieht aus wie Amazon für Arme.
Es ist ja auch im Prinzip das China-Amazon für Arme.
Ich kenne die,
ich kenne keinen Vergleich dazwischen,
aber mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn AliExpress und gerade mit dem ganzen Marketplace,
wenn die nicht sogar größer sind,
größer sind als Amazon.
Moin, Cooper1338.
Warum eigentlich 1338 und nicht die magische 1337?
So viele Streams.
Ja, ich habe euch ja gestern schon gesagt,
es ist ganz merkwürdig aktuell,
gerade was mit Streams bei mir ist.
Und zwar,
ich habe abends gerade so das Gefühl,
irgendwie ist der Tag nicht vollständig,
ohne eine Runde gestreamt zu haben.
Aber macht euch keine Gedanken,
das hält nicht lange.
1337 war vollkommen vergeben.
Ja, so.
Verstehe.
Wir kaufen jetzt erst einmal was ein,
bevor wir wieder ewig rumschwätzen.
Fragen machen wir gleich,
die wir noch haben von gestern.
Also, ich weiß nämlich,
was ich unbedingt brauche.
Und zwar, das ist eine Sache,
die kaufen wir tatsächlich in der UK ein.
Ich brauche nämlich...
Oh, oh, der Tainser, schau wieder.
Was ist denn los mit dem?
Da gab es Gehaltserhöhungen.
Dankeschön, drei Abos.
Huge.
Äh, den da.
Nee, nicht den da.
Der passt jetzt nicht wirklich, ja.
Der da.
Nein, ein, ein, ein, ein nicer.
Da kommt der Scam-Train auch gleich.
Dankeschön.
Huge Subs.
Für wen haben wir denn?
Ähm, haben wir denn?
Wer hat denn welche gekriegt?
Mango Käse.
P, E, E.
Excellent.
Da passt bestimmt hier Exquisite.
Excellent droht mal dazu.
Ähm, auch wenn ich überhaupt nichts trinke,
was das angeht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das Emo drin habe.
Wahrscheinlich einfach nur, weil es mit Pfeif hat.
Keine Ahnung, weil ich dummes Zeug vor mich hin schwätze.
Ähm, Turbo.
Turbo Dead End hat auch eins gekriegt.
Und A underscore Casper kriegt auch eins.
Wahnsinn.
Der IQ des Chats, überhaupt des Streams,
ist wieder fast schon oben angekommen.
Viel höher geht es kaum.
Ice Freak ist wieder am Start.
Acht Monate.
Huge.
Richtig krasser Hacker-Name ist das.
Der Scam-Train ist noch nicht am Start, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht können wir den irgendwie beschwören.
Was ist jetzt mit der Musik?
Die Musik ist aus.
Kann er sich mal entscheiden?
Kann er?
Okay.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach die nächste Playlist.
Vielleicht ist die ausgewogener.
Kennt jemand irgendein, so ein Kompressor-Plugin für ein Chrome,
dass ich den Sound von der Playlist immer gleich laut habe?
Oh, der ist huge.
Die, die, die.
Haben wir jetzt in AdWords hier,
dass die Kanalpunkte automatisch sammeln?
Was sowas gibt's?
Ja, Ice Freak, danke schön für acht Monate.
Huge High IQ Subscription.
Was für Internetverträge hast du?
Ich habe von Unity Media noch,
was jetzt ja Vodafone ist,
ähm,
40 ab und 400 down.
Ich hoffe, ich erzähle jetzt keinen Mist.
Ja, 40 ab, 400 down.
Ich bezahle Power-Upload lustigerweise doppelt.
Weil sie mich scamast haben, äh,
Hardcore.
Scammed haben sie mich.
Ich bezahle doppelt ein Power-Upload,
kriege aber nur einfach ein Power-Upload.
Könntest du mal erklären,
für was Kubernetes sinnvoll wäre?
Boah, das Thema hatten wir schon ein paar Mal
und ich will es jetzt nicht wieder so sehr ausdehnen.
Also, unabhängig von Kubernetes.
Ähm, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Kubernetes,
ist das, sagen wir mal so, ist das, ist das verbreitete?
Was gibt's da noch?
Mesos und ach, alle möglichen Dinger.
Wenn du für dich entschieden hast,
dass Container an sich eine gute Lösung sind
für deinen Anwendungszweck,
wann ist Kubernetes sinnvoll?
Also, ein, ein, ich bring dir noch mal ein Beispiel,
Rest, ihr müsst ja denken,
weil das muss ich wieder ewig lang da drum herum erzählen
und eigentlich will ich jetzt was einkaufen.
Und zwar, mal angenommen, du hast irgendeinen Service,
der schwankende User hat, schwankende Userzahlen.
Oder du hast ein MMO, was ein Add-on launcht, irgendwas.
Stell dir einfach was vor, wo du schwankende Userzahlen hast.
Und, ähm, du weißt ungefähr,
vielleicht, wenn du Glück hast, wann viel kommt,
aber so ganz sicher bist du dir nicht.
Und, äh, da, bei solchen Sachen kann Kubernetes
die Stärken ganz gut ausspielen,
weil du kannst halt deine Containerinfrastruktur
ziemlich gut skalieren.
Und du bezahlst, wenn du es dann auch,
sagen wir mal so, wenn Azure laufen lässt,
bezahlst du halt auch nur das, was du benutzt.
Also, du musst dir dann keine 20 VMs
oder 20 Hardwarekisten bei Hetzner Cloud,
oder sonst wo, mieten,
dass du, dass du quasi deinen
Benutzeransturm abfangen kannst, der kommen könnte.
Nee, du kannst auf Sparflamme fahren,
wenn keine Sau dein, dein MMO spielt.
Aber, wenn dann mal PewDiePie dein, äh,
MMO-Let's Played und auf einmal
85 Billiarden Leute,
wo sag ich denn, Michael?
5, 5, 5 Billiarden, ähm, in dein MMO rein wollen,
dann kannst du ganz easy einfach deine Server skalieren
und machst aus zwei Servern
120 Server und alles, alles läuft, äh.
Dafür zum Beispiel ist das gut.
Kann man hier Fragen stellen, kannst du machen, ja.
Wenn es interessiert, Titanfall 2 ist bei Amazon für
5 Euro im Angebot, das ist gut.
Spiel ist toll.
Also ganz ehrlich, Titanfall und der Multiplayer,
keine Ahnung, aber die Singleplayer-Kampagne,
die ist wirklich nice.
Wollten wir nicht Titanfall...
Moment, Leute, hatten wir nicht mal die Titanfall-Kampagne angefangen
und wollten die fertig spielen?
War da nicht was?
Haben wir nicht mal Titanfall im Stream angefangen
und wollten die fertig spielen?
Und haben das nie gemacht?
Hast du noch dein Backup-Anschluss von der Telekom?
Nee.
Würdest du aktuell einen Kauf von Battlefield 5 empfehlen?
Boah, keine Ahnung, ich hab Battlefield 5 seit
bisschen am Release nie wieder gespielt.
Nicht ablenken, ja, hast recht.
Ob es jemals Titanfall 3 geben wird, ich denk schon.
Auch wenn sich nicht gut verkauft hat.
Also, äh, was ich einkaufen muss,
und das ist jetzt ne Sache, das ist nicht so,
so spassernde Freund, China, China-Shopping,
sondern es sind ein paar Sachen, die brauch ich wirklich.
Und zwar, ähm, ich hab euch ja erzählt,
ich hab ja, ich hab hier ein paar Kameras im Einsatz,
zum größten Teil sind das ja die hier,
hab ich euch ja schon erzählt, weil es gute Custom-Firmware gibt,
aber, ich, äh, hab auch nen Raspberry Pi
am Start mit ner Kamera fürs Hoftor.
Also für, für, dass man sieht, wer, wer an der Tür steht.
Und, ähm, ich wollt noch ein paar andere Raspberry Pis
mit Kameras hinstellen, um genau zu sein.
Einen noch dazu.
Noch dazu nehm ich dann die Garage.
Und, ähm, ich wollte auch den Raspberry Pi,
den ich oben hier, äh, für, für, äh, die Haustür hab,
den wollte ich noch ein bisschen umbauen,
weil der hängt aktuell ein bisschen,
ein bisschen ungeschickt montiert, so schräg an der Wand.
Mit Heißkleber.
So, und wer schon mal Sachen mit Heißkleber
an der Wand befestigt hat, der kann sich,
oder es kann sich wahrscheinlich jeder denken,
das hält net so lang.
Die Idee war eher so auf die Schnelle,
dass das Ding hält.
Also im Prinzip hab ich das Ding in den Schrumpfschlauch,
hab ich meinen Raspberry Pi in den Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt
und hab den Schrumpfschlauch, ähm, an die, an die Wand
heißklebert.
Also, genauso, genauso wie man's macht, ja.
So, das ist mir natürlich aufgefallen,
okay, es wär ziemlich blöd, wenn der Raspberry Pi
mit dem, von der Heißkleber abgeht,
es ist, es regnet vielleicht, es ist ein bisschen windig,
und dann fliegt dein Raspberry Pi samt Schrumpfschlauch,
quer über die Straße und landet irgendwo sonst,
und ist weg.
Das ist keine gute Idee,
deswegen wollte ich das jetzt ordentlich machen,
und, ähm, den Raspberry Pi hinter eine Abdeckung machen,
und die Kamera vom Raspberry Pi, die ich halt brauche
für den Eingangsbereich, vor der, vor der Eingangstür,
die wollte ich halt an der Stelle lassen,
wo jetzt der Raspberry Pi ist.
Der kommt dann auch in den Schrumpfschlauch rein,
Schrumpfschlauch kommt vielleicht in ein kleines Loch rein,
dass die Kamera durchpasst und gut ist.
Funktioniert an sich wunderbar.
Ich kann's euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen,
weil es so viel liegt, und sowas, ja.
So, deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich muss mal eh ein paar,
ich wollte eh noch ein paar Raspberry Pi Sachen kaufen,
das können wir mal bei der Gelegenheit grad machen,
und bei dem Shop hier kauf ich eigentlich ganz gerne einen,
da hab ich schon öfters Raspberry Pi Zeug gekauft.
Die hatten auch mal nen deutschen Shop,
hey, sitzt gerade an einem Onlinekurs,
jetzt noch? So spät?
1952, was ist denn da los?
So, die hatten nämlich mal nen deutschen Shop,
Problem ist, der ist RIP.
Aber das macht nichts, die Versandzeiten sind trotzdem schnell.
Die versenden jetzt aus UK,
man kann hier glaube ich umstellen auch auf Euro,
aber nimmt sich im Prinzip nicht viel.
Mittlerweile ist es eh bei mir so merkwürdig,
wenn ich Sachen bezahle,
ich bezahle in Pfund,
also bei dem Shop hier zum Beispiel,
ich bezahle in Pfund über PayPal,
was dann selbst über US-Dollar ist.
Mein PayPal ist US-Dollar aus dem Grund,
weil ich dort ein paar Zahlungen bekommen hab in US-Dollar.
Was heißt das?
Also eigentlich brauch ich überhaupt keine Euro mehr,
gerade zum Bezahlen.
Genau, also, was ich mal suchen wollte,
ob die sowas haben,
da bin ich mir nämlich gar nicht so sicher,
als Kamera für den Raspberry Pi Zero hab ich das Ding,
zeig euch mal, so ne ganz kleine,
wobei, das haben die hier bestimmt auch,
Pi Zero Camera.
So ne ganz, so ne furze kleine hab ich.
Und zwar, hier, beste.
Richtig, richtig nice Musik.
Ähm, wo ist sie?
Die da, die hab ich.
Die ist gerade am Raspberry dran,
der ein Kamerabild von der Eingangstür liefert.
So, und was da das Problem ist,
was man jetzt hier teilweise erkennt ist,
das ist so ein kleines Furzkabel,
so ein ganz kurzes, so ein ganz kurzes, kleines,
und das geht auch nur in den Raspberry Pi dran.
Also das ist, pff, klar, und was ist das?
Zwo Zentimeter?
Monka DSGVO.
Also ich glaube, da werde ich keine Probleme mit kriegen.
Aber, man weiß ja heutzutage nie, ja.
Zumindest, es ist halt ziemlich, ziemlich kurz und klein,
deswegen hab ich den Raspberry Pi auch gerade mit Heißkleber an die Wand gemacht,
weil ihr seht, die Reichweite vom Pi mit der Kamera ist net allzu hoch.
Ähm, was, äh, ein Du, Dodo,
ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist ein Dude, aber ist es gar nicht, es ist ein Dodo.
Ähm, welche Custom-Firmware hast du auf den Wisecams?
Wollte mir demnächst gerne eine Überwachungskamera basteln,
aber möchte nicht, was haben da ständig nach China telefoniert?
Die hier.
Github.
Dafang.
Hex.
Die da.
Ähm, da musst du mal gucken, ob es nicht irgendwelche Probleme gibt mit neuerer Firmware,
dass man die nicht mehr flashen kann oder sonst was,
aber ansonsten, die Custom-Firmware ist wirklich super für die Kameras,
man kann absolut nichts sagen.
Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass die gerade in der Kerndisziplin,
nämlich RTSP-Streaming,
ein bisschen Feintuning braucht, was die Settings ist.
Also du darfst die Bitrate auf jeden Fall nicht sonderlich hochstellen,
also du kannst jetzt da nicht mit, auch wenn du es einstellen kannst,
also du kannst das in der Firmware einstellen,
dass du, sagen wir mal, irgendwie 30 FPS,
1080p,
30 FPS,
äh, 15 Mbit, kannst du einstellen, aber
die Kamera, plus Motion Detection,
die, die, die kackt dir komplett ab, die Kamera.
Die spackt übelst rum, wenn du es zu hoch stellst,
also du brauchst ein bisschen Feintuning,
was die, was die Stream-Settings angeht.
Und die Kamera profitiert extrem davon,
und wirklich ernsthaft, extrem davon,
wenn sie guten WLAN-Empfang hat.
Die haben wohl ziemlich miese Antennen drin, ne?
Und ich, ich, ich hatte, als ich nur noch,
als ich, als ich einen Access Point hatte,
ähm, hat es geruckelt ohne Ende, ne?
Und als ich jetzt unten noch einen zweiten Access Point hingestellt habe,
läuft es auf einmal butterweich.
Ne, da ist kein ESP8266 in der Kamera,
wollen wir, Leute, wollen wir gucken, was in der Kamera drin ist.
Wir können gucken, was in der Kamera drin ist, wenn ihr wollt.
Wir gucken, was in der Kamera drin ist.
Ich habe hier alles bei mir geroutet mit Custom-Firmware.
root, add, 60, 101, glaube ich.
Nein, da, doch hier.
Also, da ist die Kamera.
Was ist da drinne?
Proc, CPU-Info.
Das ist drinne.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut ist, was es ist.
Also hier, laut der Leistung ist der,
laut der Leistung ist der, ist die CPU
im Staubsauger
dreimal so schnell.
Die CPU in meinem Staubsauger ist dreimal so schnell wie in der Kamera.
Also, ist nichts tolles, was da drinne ist.
Und CPU-technisch kannst du da echt keine großen Sprünge machen,
was die Kamera anbelangt.
Aber der hat natürlich ein Hardware-H264-Decoder.
Und deswegen funktioniert das Bild ganz gut.
So, also, was ich brauch, ist,
ich brauch erstens nochmal ne zweite,
ähm, Weitwinkel-Mini-Mini-Picam.
Und ihr seht's ja hier, die Dinger sind wirklich saumäßig klein.
Also, wer schon immer mal
ne Kamera, am besten, wenn er irgendwo ne Abdeckung hat,
schon mal immer irgendwo ne Kamera verstecken wollte,
ich stifte keinen hierzu was an.
Ich sag nur, falls es mal jemand vorhat.
Natürlich müsst ihr selbst darauf achten,
dass ihr das nur zu legalen Zwecken verwendet,
dass jetzt keiner am Ende ankommt und sagt,
Max, äh, Monka DSGVO und Anzeige ist raus.
Ne, da seid ihr komplett selbst für verantwortlich.
Ähm, also wenn ihr schon irgendwo mal
so ne Mini-Spycam irgendwo haben wolltet,
und sei es auch nur um zu gucken,
ob in eurem Garten nachts irgendwelche
fremden Katzen sich kloppen oder so,
ähm, die ist wirklich gut.
Die ist ziemlich klein.
Und man muss sagen,
obwohl das so ne kleine Furzkamera ist,
hat die ne verhältnismäßig große, ähm,
wie nennt man das, wenn man Bilder auch im Dunkeln ganz gut machen kann?
Also natürlich nicht zu vergleichen mit ner ordentlichen Kamera,
aber wenn man die Bitrate, äh, wenn man die Bildrate runterstellt,
ich hab die Bildrate bei mir so eingestellt,
dass nachts die Bildrate auf 2 Frames pro Sekunde runtergeht,
und da ist es nur mit, nur mit, äh, äh,
Laternenbeleuchtung auf der Straße so hell
im Videofeed, dass ich Leute erkenne,
wenn sie an der Haustür stehen.
Also, die ist ganz okay für so ein kleines Furzding.
Äh, Auflösung hat die, die haben bis zu 2400 noch was,
aber das benutze ich nicht.
Ich benutze, ähm,
glaub, was benutze ich denn?
Glaub 720p.
Ich benutze 720p.
Das muss man nämlich auch ein bisschen schauen,
je nach Auflösung, die man verwendet, ist der,
wird irgendwie ein anderer Bereich vom Sensor benutzt oder so,
und die beste,
mir ging's nicht so sehr um die beste Auflösung,
sondern um den besten, um die beste Abdeckung.
Und die beste Abdeckung, quasi Sichtfeld,
also das größte Sichtfeld,
mit der Kamera hab ich bei 720p.
Und wie gesagt, nachts geht das Ganze auf 2 FPS runter,
und dann ist es rein mit Straßenbeleuchtung hell genug.
Das heißt, ich brauch keine, ich brauch keine, äh, Infrarot,
äh, LEDs, die dann irgendwie, äh,
nachtsig Gedöns machen oder so.
Straßenlaternenbeleuchtung reicht in dem Fall.
Bei 2 FPS.
Gehst auf 2 FPS runter und schon hast du gute Beleuchtung.
Gut.
Äh, also, wenn ich hier von gut rede,
heißt das, man erkennt was.
Es ist absolut nicht zu vergleichen mit ordentlichen Kameras,
aber das sollte, glaub ich, jedem klar sein,
wenn er dieses kleine Furzding hier sieht,
ähm, allein schon, wie, wie
popelig der Sensor ist und wie wenig Licht da reinkommt.
Ähm, so, so welche brauch ich.
Und ihr kennt ja, 2 FPS,
2 FPS ist dann nicht mehr Max-FPS.
Doch, natürlich.
1 FPS für jedes Auge.
So, dass man noch was erkennt.
Äh, welche Software verwendest du dafür für die Aufnahme,
dass das variabel geht?
Äh, ich starte den Stream einfach neu.
Bei Sonnenuntergang.
Normalerweise tagsüber läuft's mit 15 oder 20
oder irgendwie, weiß nicht, was ich da eingestellt hab, normal.
Ähm, und abends startet's kurz den Stream neu.
Äh, das dauert ja eine halbe Sekunde,
bis der Stream neu gestartet ist.
Äh, mit 2, mit 2 Sekunden.
Das mach ich über, über G-Streamer.
Und meine, meine Kameraüberwachungssoftware,
wo wir auch hier mal ein bisschen im Stream rumprogrammiert haben,
die ruft sich das Bild von der Kamera ab.
Die ist übrigens mittlerweile so advanced
und kann direkt Raspberry-Pi-Videosignale abgreifen.
Hat die Kamera auch RTX?
Das müssen wir vielleicht mal, müssen wir mal fragen.
Müssen wir mal fragen, ob Nvidia nicht sowas bauen möchte.
Die hat, die hat echtes Raytracing.
Die braucht kein, kein 3D-Fake-Raytracing.
Äh, Neonimus, ja, das ist ja heute immer noch so.
Das menschlich, nee, das menschliche Auge kann nicht mehr als 24 FPS sehen,
haben sie immer erzählt damals.
Das menschliche Auge kann nicht mehr als 24 FPS sehen.
Ähm, war immer, ging da immer so das Gerücht um auf YouTube.
Totaler Schwachsinn.
So.
Leute, ich hab's euch jetzt ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt im Stream.
Was machen wir, wenn wir was kaufen?
Was ist das Wichtigste, wenn man Technik-Sachen bestellt,
die auch schnell kaputt gehen?
Wer es weiß, kriegt eine Rolle Klopapier wieder.
Lack?
Debated.
Lack nix.
Custom-Firmware?
Ja, richtig, richtig, Custom-Firmware.
Aber in dem Fall ist es Raspberry Pi, da ist auch schon genug Custom-Firmware.
Bulk-Order, ja?
Direkt 20 Stück?
Ich sehe schon, ich sehe schon der Chat.
Der Chat ist durch die ganzen Subscriber heute wirklich IQ-mäßig komplett, ähm,
also, der platzt schon fast.
Und der Chat hat's natürlich wieder erkannt.
Und zwar, wir kaufen drei.
Die sind nur Profis.
Das heißt, wir kaufen drei.
Ähm, eine geht mir zu schnell kaputt, wenn ich, wenn ich nicht aufpasse.
Und, äh, zwei, sag drei ist die beste Zahl.
Bam.
Drei reicht.
Drei Stück, kommen wir.
So.
So, und dann, so, da haben wir die Kamera.
Dann brauchen wir jetzt, und da hab ich letztens was gesehen bei denen.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht, wie das Ding heißt.
So, ihr habt ja gesehen, das hat so ein Mini, so ein kleines Furzkabel.
So was brauche ich, genau.
Genau das habe ich gesucht.
WTF, ich dachte, ich suche das jetzt eine halbe Stunde suchen auf den ihrer Seite.
Bis ich das, fünf, fünf ist eine glatte Zahl.
Also, mal ganz im Ernst.
Drei ist genauso glatt, wie fünf, wenn fünf glatt wäre.
Na, jetzt gibt's doch wirklich keinen Unterschied dazwischen, ne.
Aber fünf ist geiler.
Überlegt euch mal, überlegt euch mal, Chat.
Big Brain.
Oder Small Brain, je nachdem.
Überlegt euch mal, wenn ihr Primzahlen Paare habt.
Also Paare in Form von.
Es ist immer nur eine gerade Zahl dazwischen.
Weil ich meine, zwei Primzahlen, außer zwei und drei.
Die können ja nicht nebeneinander liegen, direkt.
Weil da kommt ja immer noch eine gerade Zahl dazwischen.
Eine gerade Zahl kann ja keine Primzahl sein.
Aber überlegt euch mal, wenn ihr Primzahlen Paare habt.
Da liegt dann ja, also eine gerade Zahl dazwischen.
Und wusstet ihr, dass vermutet wird.
Oder vielleicht sogar schon bewiesen ist.
Bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher.
Ob diese gerade Zahl immer durch sechs teilbar ist.
Excellent.
Ich glaub, das ist sogar bewiesen.
Ja, das ist bewiesen.
War euch das klar, Chat?
Nein, neun und elf.
Also neun ist schon mal keine Primzahl.
Guckt mal.
Guckt euch mal nur die ersten Paar an.
Of course, simple.
Excellent.
Guckt euch mal die ersten an.
Fünf und sieben.
Was liegt dazwischen?
Sechs.
Elf und dreizehn.
Was liegt da sieben?
Was liegt dazwischen?
Zwölf.
Zwölf durch sechs?
Kein Ding.
Oder Vielfaches von sechs.
So.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Sieben und neunzehn.
Was liegt dazwischen?
Achtzehn.
Achtzehn durch sechs.
Was haben wir hier?
Einundvierzig, dreinundvierzig.
Was liegt daneben?
Zweiundvierzig.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt aus dem Kopf keine Ahnung, ob man das durch sechs teilen kann.
Aber ich würde jetzt mal davon ausgehen.
Na?
Jetzt haben wir wieder was gelernt.
Wieder was gelernt, Chat.
Excellent.
Was ihr jetzt damit anfangen sollt, weiß ich nicht genau.
Die andere Ausnahme sind übrigens drei und fünf.
Drei und fünf?
Aber...
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Drei und fünf, da hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht, ja.
Damit wirst du irgendwann flexen.
Ja, mach das mal, Leute.
Denn wenn da Sibaro da wäre...
Sibaro.
Sibaro, bist du da?
Da ist er.
Also, falls...
Ähm...
Falls...
Falls dein Physik-Grill irgendwann mal wieder frei wird, die kannst du damit bestimmt beeindrucken.
Kannst sagen...
Hast du schon gewusst, wenn du Primzahlen-Paare hast...
Das gefällt der bestimmt.
Ähm...
Chico SS...
Das ist irgendwie von der Aussprache her ein bisschen Fail, oder?
Sagen wir...
Sagen wir eher Chico ES ES.
Ja.
es ex exzellent name übrigens meine katze heißt auch chico dank für die zwei monate
so also kamera haben eingekauft ich brauche jetzt noch weiter geht's ich brauche jetzt
auch den kamera adapter wir haben drei kameras also kaufen drei kamera adapter excellent so
was das ding macht ist das habe ich erst letztens gefunden in dem shop dass sie sowas am start haben
das macht das mini kabel von pi zero auf ein normales kabel was man dann in normale raspberry
pi stecken kann und das juckt mich gar nicht so sehr wichtig für mich ist dass ich das hier auch
verlängern kann und das andere nicht gut davon drei stück kann man schon hinzugefügt dann
brauchen wir noch ein paar dinge die wir noch nicht haben und die wir noch nicht haben und
brauchen wir noch ich überlege gerade ob ich mir noch einen zweiten pi was was was kosten aktuell
die raspberry pi 4 dinge hier gab es hier nicht gerade irgendwo im angebot habe ich nicht gesehen
dass irgendwo raspberry pi 4s im angebot sind raspberry pi 4s im angebot habe ich doch irgendwo
gesehen ah hier auf der offiziellen ja auf der home seite du meinst bei denen hier auf der
home seite oder ach ach so
oder zwei gigabyte zum preis von einem gut eigentlich brauche ich ja gar keine 4 gigabyte
variante da reicht einer der stream ruckelt nicht ich habe ich habe es im blick so vodafone also ich
habe auch forscher als bei mir wirklich gar nichts da holen wir da noch ein so und was jetzt noch brauche ist
ich brauche kamera kabel um das ganze bisschen zu
verlängern was hier brauche ich ja ich bin mir
nicht ganz wie weit kann man den kram verlängern ich glaube nicht dass die
kamera mit zwei meter noch ordentlich funktioniert das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen
diese kabel sind nicht für lange übertragung strecken gigantic box sache
ich 50 cm hat das reicht 50 cm ist okay vielleicht 256 310 meter im angebot also
Umso kürzer, umso besser für diese kleinen Fotzkabel wahrscheinlich.
Na gut, nachdem der Kram ja wirklich nichts kostet, machen wir mal drei Stück davon und drei Stück davon.
So, brauchen wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Lass mal überlegen, was haben die noch so alles, wenn man Kameras sich anguckt?
Gibt es da vielleicht noch irgendwas, wo man sich inspirieren lassen kann?
Kauft noch zwei Meter und schneid die ab.
Exzellent Idee.
Beste.
Gibt es da vielleicht sonst noch Sachen, die einen irgendwie inspirieren?
Was ist das denn?
Three-in-one-Camera-Lens-Set.
Das sackt doch, oder?
Das sackt doch Balls, das Ding.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das ist Müll.
Eine Telephoto-Lens.
Du meinst, wenn ich schon meine Eingangstür-Kamera habe, dann sollte ich auch so...
Aber da...
Also erstens kostet das viel, das stimmt.
Uli Renach, sagst du recht.
Außerdem, das ist mega fett.
Ich sage, ich kaufe mir doch nicht eine Mini-Kamera.
Ich kaufe mir doch nicht so eine Mini-Kamera, um am Ende so eine fette Linse davor zu machen.
War da ein Pi mit Gehäuse?
Nö, habe ich noch.
Habe ich noch.
Im Zweifelsfall kann ich auch mal wieder meinen 3D-Drucker bemühen.
Aber Pi-Gehäuse habe ich noch.
Stimmt, doch.
Ich wollte noch...
Ich wollte doch...
Aha.
Pi-Case.
Ich wollte doch mal dieses Alu-Gehäuse-Ding da ausprobieren.
Haben die sowas hier?
Haben die nicht, oder?
What?
Wie wird das da alles versehen mit DHL?
Ich wollte doch mal die ganze Zeit schon...
Pi-4-Case.
Ich wollte zwei Raspberry Pi-Cases ausprobieren.
Nämlich einmal diesen Alu-Block.
Das habe ich glaube ich gerade aktuell...
Warte, was habe ich denn aktuell für eins?
Das habe ich aktuell.
Das ist nicht so toll.
Das ist ein ziemliches Sacker-Gehäuse.
Ich wollte einmal diesen Alu-Block ausprobieren.
Und einmal das andere, was wir gesehen haben.
Wie heißt das?
Das eine irgendwie...
Flier?
Ne, ähm...
Flar?
Flier?
Flum?
Wie ist das Gehäuse?
Ah, Big Brain.
Und das andere hieß wie...
Ah, Ah, Ah...
Agorn oder so, ne?
Genau.
Das ist glaube ich das eine, was ich mal ausprobieren wollte.
Ne, Flier ist nachts.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist was anderes, genau.
So, das ist das eine, was ich mal ausprobieren wollte an Cases.
Das fand ich ganz cool.
Vor allem, weil die auch hier...
Farbige Pin-Ausgaben und so am Start haben.
Das ist das eine, was ich ausprobieren wollte.
Moment, was gibt es da vor?
Und was gibt es da...
Wow.
Warum haben die da 30, 30 Dinger?
Wo ist da der Unterschied?
Ah, da ist noch irgendetwas komisches.
Genau, das Case wollte ich nämlich mal ausprobieren.
Wie heißt das?
Wie heißt...
Wie hieß denn das andere?
Dieser Alu...
Flair.
Bestimmt Flair.
Scheiß Fanboy.
Ähm...
Flair C?
Kann das sein?
Ja, das ist es, glaube ich.
Aber das haben die nicht, ja?
Das wollte ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Das ist da wirklich...
Ja, das...
Genau, das meine ich hier.
Das ist es, glaube ich, was ich ausprobieren wollte.
Es sagt aber dann, warum gibt es das bei Amazon nicht.
Das ist es doch, oder?
Das ist so ein Fake-Nachbau, ist das hier.
Gebate-Nachbau.
Ach, scheiße, auf ein Gehäuse tut es auch erst mal.
Oh, das sieht ja hässlich aus.
Das sieht aus, als hätte das irgendwie einer aus so einem Block rausgefräst,
der nicht gemessen hat, ob das passt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Nee, irgendwie gibt es das gerade nicht.
Vielleicht gibt es das auch gar nicht bei Amazon, überhaupt nicht.
Na gut, wird eben auch sein.
Das holen wir auf jeden Fall.
Das wollte ich nämlich schon mal die ganze Zeit ausprobieren.
Das Case.
Einfach, weil es geht.
So, save Amazon.
Easy.
Die haben es ja leider nicht, sonst hätte ich eine komplette Bestellung bei denen machen können.
Hast du eigentlich einen 3D-Drucker?
Ja, habe ich.
Also, ich könnte mir auch eins 3D drucken, das ist kein Ding,
aber ein 3D-gedrucktes Gehäuse hat halt kein ordentliches Heat-Sink.
Die haben ja nur ziemlich eklige Gehäuse, ne?
Sackt.
So, wie wir jetzt einfach schon mal 120 Euro ausgegeben haben für Dinger.
Das brauchst du doch unbedingt.
Okay, was ist das?
WTF, was ist das?
What?
Warum soll ich einen Tower-Kühler auf meinen Raspberry Pi drauf machen?
Max, hast du so einen Feinstaubsensor?
Oh, gute Idee.
Neko, gute Idee.
So ein Ding wollte ich mir...
So ein Air-Quality-Sensor.
Wollte ich mir...
Tatsächlich kaufen.
Gut, dass du mich dran erinnerst.
Okay, warum...
Also...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu genau sagen soll.
Hauptsache RGB.
Ich überlege mir gerade den Einsatzzweck.
Luftdaten.info.
Was braucht man da für einen Sensor für?
SDS 011.
Okay, das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Guck mal gleich nochmal bei AliExpress hin.
Hast du schon mal eine Mehrwertsteuer nachgezahlt bei der Lieferung?
Ja, ich habe furchtbar, wo ich zum Zollen musste, zum Beispiel.
Musste ich nachbezahlen, ja.
Hm...
Also, ich erkenne absolut nicht den Sinn dahinter.
Hinter diesem Lüfter.
Das leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein.
Ich meine, ja, der Raspberry Pi 4 wird warm.
Aber das kann man auch deutlich angenehmer als mit so einem fetten Lüfter...
...beheben.
Ja, zum Beispiel in einem gescheiten Gehäuse, wo dann im Zweifelsfall ein Lüfter drin ist.
Oder in einem Alu-Gehäuse.
Aber das macht den Raspberry Pi unnötig fett, unnötig groß, unnötig unhandlich.
Und gleichermaßen ist er nicht in einem Gehäuse, dass er keinen Staub fängt.
Also, eigentlich ist es kompletter Schwachsinn, oder?
Sehe ich da irgendwas nicht richtig dran?
Denk doch mal ans RGB.
Wasserkühlung.
Flüssig-Stickstoff-Fett schon.
Was ist denn das?
Wie viele hässliche Raspberry Pi-Gehäuse gibt es denn hier eigentlich alles?
Was ist das für ein...
What the fuck?
Monka.
Das ist das in...
Mini Raspberry Pi Rack, in Anführungsstrichen, mit, ähm, einem 120mm-Lüfter hinten dran.
Wa...
Äh...
Pfff...
Ja, warum nicht, ja?
Wenn man...
Wenn man vier Raspberry Pi 4 übereinander stapeln will, dann ist der Lüfter bestimmt nicht verkehrt.
Hallo, was habe ich verpasst?
Wir haben Raspberry Pi-Sachen eingekauft in England.
Wie heißt die Sache?
wo du das bestellen willst, hier Pimoroni, bei denen habe ich schon öfters bestellt,
die sind nicht schlecht, was ich bei denen auch ganz gut finde, du kannst direkt über
Paypal und Amazon Pay bezahlen und musst nicht normalen Checkout machen und nicht Adresse
eingeben, so alles überhaupt. Kannst dich auch so, was du nehmen willst, was dir lieber ist.
Also, es ist beides kompletter Schwachsinn. Söyd Rand, 10 Monate, excellent subscription.
Dankeschön, nice, und wen haben wir noch am Start? Den SPNboy123, für 2 Monate, auch
Dankeschön für dein Subscription, huge, Hyper Subscription. Ehm, ein Pi Cluster hat
sich mir noch nie erschlossen, Cooper, mir auch nicht. Den einzigen Anwendungszweck,
der mir so entfernt einfällt, für einen Raspberry Pi Cluster ist, wenn man ein bisschen
mit Clustern, mit Clustern, mit Clustern, mit Clustern, mit Clustern, mit Clustern, mit
Clustern, Clustersachen üben möchte. Also, vielleicht wenn man sich nen CephFS Cluster,
Cluster bauen will, oder nen, nen, n equaponetes Ding daheim oder sonstwas. Aber nur zum üben.
Nicht um da wirklich, was ernsthaft drauf zu betreiben. Das ist halt einfach nur unnötig
die Komplexität für den Heimbereich und sorgt wahrscheinlich dafür, dass die Sachen daheim
mehr down sind, durch die Hochverfügbarkeitslösungen, als das die Hochverfügbarkeitslö-sung,
was bringen. Ja, aber zu üben kannst du dir auch was auf GKC. Was ist denn? Oh them.
Ist GKC die Google Cloud?
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie man den Kram abkürzt.
Ja, da klingt es nach Google, wenn es 300 Dollar sind.
Ja, die 300 Dollar habe ich auch schon für die Google Cloud.
Okay, das ist Schwachsinn, das kaufe ich mir nicht.
Ihr wisst, ich kaufe mir gerne Schwachsinn.
Aber das ist Schwachsinn, den brauche ich wirklich nicht.
Den werde ich nie verwenden.
Bei dem Lüfter habe ich ja mal kurz überlegt, ob ich nicht einfach nur, weil es lustig ist,
mir so einen Raspberry Pi Tower Lüfter kaufen soll.
Einfach nur, weil es lustig ist.
Aber ich meine, es sind nur 19 Euro.
Aber wozu? Warum?
Das ergibt in dem Fall eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich glaube, ich lasse es mal echt bleiben.
Hier sind ein paar Sensoren für den Pi.
Ich glaube, ich habe fast alles an Sensoren, was es gibt.
Fast alles. Fast alles mittlerweile.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was ich davon habe.
Gucken wir mal, was ich davon habe.
Temperaturluft? Ja.
Warum wird die Seite jetzt einfach dunkel?
Hack ist raus.
Adblock vielleicht.
Ja, vielleicht.
Vielleicht hat sich jetzt noch eingekriegt.
Also Temperaturluftfeuchtigkeit.
Temperatur...
Alter, dann wird halt Dunkelseite, meinetwegen.
38 Skripts, was hast du mir da für eine Seite geschickt?
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das für eine Seite?
Also, lass mal sehen.
So.
Guck mal, Temperatursensoren habe ich.
Luftfeuchtigkeitssensoren habe ich.
Luftdrucksensoren habe ich auch.
Gassensoren habe ich nicht.
Bewegungssensoren habe ich sogar.
Six Axes irgendwie, sonst wie Acceleration, Bewegung, sonst was.
Navigationsmodule habe ich keins.
Ich habe ein paar GPS-Module.
Funk habe ich.
Infrarot habe ich.
Bluetooth habe ich auch.
Motoren benutze ich keine.
Analoge Sensoren habe ich massig.
Kann man gleich gucken.
Stromversorgung habe ich auch.
Jede Menge Konverter.
Displays habe ich.
Displays muss ich übrigens.
Bei AliExpress noch welche bestellen.
Davon habe ich tatsächlich welche da.
Sowohl DHT11 als auch DHT22, wobei ich die nicht verwende,
sondern ich verwende die Kombinations-BME-Blah-irgendwas.
Das ist Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, Luftdruck in einem.
Davon habe ich auch welche.
Allerdings habe ich die in einer wasserdichten,
Probe drin.
Da hängt einer im Fischteich hinten.
DS18B20.
Ja, genau.
Davon habe ich mir auch noch einen Fünferpack damals geholt.
Wie gesagt, ich bestelle immer noch mehrere Packs.
Der hängt hinten im Fischteich drin.
Und das ist auch so eine absolute Big Brain-Lösung.
Der übermittelt Sensoren von der Temperatur aus dem Fischteich.
Und kann dann quasi warnen.
Er weiß ja auch Wetterbericht und sonst was.
Heimautomatisierung hat ja auch Wetter.
Und wenn die Wassertemperatur unter einer...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich eingestellt habe.
Ich habe irgendwas eingestellt.
Es hat bis jetzt noch nicht angeschlagen.
Also keine Ahnung, ob es wirklich funktioniert.
Muss man mal gucken.
Zumindest wenn Wettervorhersage ist, Minustemperaturen oder Kaltfrostwarnung.
Und die Temperatur im Fischteich unter einer gewissen Gradgrenze ist,
dann ploppt in meiner Heimautomatisierung ein Warn-Popup auf.
Falls ihr noch nicht den Fischteich abgedeckt habt,
dann jetzt den Fischteich abdecken, weil sonst geht vielleicht kaputt.
Und es gibt auch eine I-Message, nee, nicht eine I-Message,
eine IOS-Notification auf die Tablets und aufs Smartphone.
So, genau.
Das ist viel besser, die BMP-Dinge.
Aber das ist nicht der Richtige.
Äh, Feuchtigkeitssensoren, da hatten wir es ja schon ein paar Mal von.
Da habe ich auch genug.
Ich habe einen Regensensor und einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Ähm, Mi Flora, das habe ich auch welche.
Genau, BME 2080, das sind die guten.
Die habe ich zum größten Teil im Einsatz, wenn es um Luftfeuchtigkeit geht.
Genau die da.
Das ist, finde ich, jetzt so preis-leistungsmäßig die beste Kombination aus Luftfeuchtigkeit,
Luftdruck und Temperatur.
So.
Ähm, von den, ähm, Mi Flora Pflanzensensoren, Regensensor, einfach aus dem Fenster schauen.
Ja, was, Fenster schauen, das ist doch alles so, so Oldschool, äh, Geschichten, ne.
Ähm, davon habe ich auch ein paar.
Die sind tatsächlich echt praktisch.
Gehen leider über Bluetooth.
Äh, davon habe ich nix, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich welche da?
Habe ich auch welche da?
Sogar, sogar die 3,3 Volt Variante.
Die habe ich extra nochmal in China damals bestellt, weil es die irgendwie bei uns hier, ähm, nicht gab.
Und habe irgendwie da 5 Wochen drauf gewartet.
Die 3,3 Volt Variante, weil die 5 Volt Variante rumspackt.
Ähm, davon habe ich auch ein paar.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Habe ich, ich habe einen, ich habe einen NFC Kartenleser, aber verwende ich nicht.
Navigationsmodule, GPS-Module habe ich ein paar.
Äh, Gyroskop habe ich welche.
Genau, das ist das, was ich vorhin gemeint habe.
Ich habe so mit Acceleration und unterschiedlichere Dinger.
Äh, Kompass habe ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Realtime-Glock brauche ich nicht, hat man ESP drinne.
Ähm, davon habe ich ein paar.
Habe ich nix, habe ich nicht, brauche ich auch nicht, wozu?
Ähm, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich mir damals ein paar Funkmodule gekauft habe.
Komplett sinnlos, habe ich für noch nie, nichts, für irgendwas verwendet.
Ähm, Funkcheckdosen haben wir ein paar.
Ja, habe ich auch welche von.
Funkcheckdosen habe ich aber noch nicht im Einsatz.
Radioempfänger, Bluetooth-Adapter, Infrarot-Diode, Lasermodule, wozu denn das?
Was mit dem, achso, Abstandsmessung oder so.
Was hier jetzt noch fehlt, was ganz praktisch ist, sind Rüttelsensoren oder Erschütterungssensoren und Lautstärkesensoren.
Beides relativ praktisch.
Zum Beispiel, was man mit einem Rüttelsensor machen kann, oder einem Vibrationssensor, ist, man kann zum Beispiel checken,
ob die Waschmaschine...
...fertig ist.
Also sprich, wenn die Waschmaschine länger als 5 Minuten nicht rüttelt, dann ist sie wohl fertig.
Gibt's aber auch, wie bei vielen Sachen daheim, zig Varianten, wie man das rauskriegen kann.
Man kann auch eine Steckdose anschließen, die den Strom misst, die die Waschmaschine braucht.
Und wenn die eine Weile nicht viel Strom braucht, dann wird sie auch fertig sein.
Also da gibt's verschiedenste Varianten, wie man das rauskriegt.
Aber ich finde, so ein Rüttelsensor ist eine gute, äh, Vibrationssensor ist eine coole Variante.
Ja, oder wenn man...
...zum Beispiel seine Klingel smart machen will, dass man eine Message geschickt kriegt, oder irgendwas, irgendwas passiert, dass man drauf reagieren kann, wenn einer seine Haustürklingel drückt.
Die einfachste Variante ist ein Lautstärkesensor.
Da nimmt man einen ESP32 oder einen ESP2866, einen kleinen Controller, und macht einen Lautstärkesensor dran und pappt es direkt an die Klingel und dann kriegt er mit, wenn es klingelt.
Gibt verschiedenste Varianten.
Da gibt es sonst nix mehr dabei, was...
Also ihr seht, ich hab...
Hier, guck mal, da ist ein Regensensor.
Regenwassersensor, genau so ein Ding.
Also ihr seht, ich hab mehr oder weniger fast alle...
Relays müssen wir halt auch noch kaufen, da brauch ich nämlich noch ein paar.
Ähm...
Pulssensoren, Schwachsinn brauch ich nicht.
Also wie ihr seht, ich hab den größten Teil...
Also das meiste hab ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise da.
Displays hab ich auch ein paar, müssen wir auch noch kaufen.
Äh, Controller haben wir auch genug.
Magnetventile, Durchflussmesser, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Äh, so einen hab ich auch am Start.
Nen, ähm...
Nen Sensor, wo man...
Da braucht man aber noch passende Elemente dazu.
Also passende Sensoren, um an den Sensor anzuschließen.
Dann kann man, äh, Druck, also Gewicht messen.
Hab ich noch nicht gebraucht.
Kamera haben wir auch.
Roboterarm, ne, aber was will ich.
Äh, da hab ich auch ein paar von.
Äh, Fotoresistor.
Den, ähm...
Verwende ich im Keller an meinem Strommesser.
Weil der Strommesser für den ersten Stock, also das, das Meter, das, äh, blinkt einmalig.
Alle so und so viel Wattstunden blinkt das einmal.
Und dieses Blinken erkennt der Fotoresistor und lockt's mit.
Wir haben auch einen analogen Stromsensor.
Und der analoge Strom, Strommesser, den lese ich mit nem Line-Sensor aus.
Line-Sensor.
So ein Ding.
Hab ich da.
Excellent.
Genau, so ein Teil.
Das ist ein Sensor, den man normalerweise zum Beispiel für irgendwelche, äh, äh, ferngesteuerten Sachen oder so verwendet.
Der erkennt, wenn der Untergrund sich ändert.
Also sprich, man kann dann, ähm, man könnte zum Beispiel irgendwie sich ein kleines Autorchen bauen mit nem Arduino oder so.
Was dann an so nem, an so ner Linie lang fährt.
Ich interessier mich überhaupt nicht für irgendwelche SCKs oder sonst was.
Aber der Sensor ist eher praktisch.
Weil, auf nem analogen Stromsensor, die Dinger nennen sich übrigens Ferraris-Zähler.
Weil die, vielleicht kennt die der ein oder andere noch.
Weil die eine Line drauf haben.
Hier sieht man's gut.
Und der Sensor erkennt das gut.
Also sprich, man macht diesen Sensor über diese Line drüber.
Das ist richtig Big Brain.
Das geht im Dunkel, das ist ein Infrarot-LED, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ähm, die musst du mal gucken.
Bei mir funktioniert's nur hier so drüber.
Hochkant.
Ich hab ne Anleitung im Internet gesehen, die hängt so rum drüber und auch in 3D, Vor-3D-Druck, wie man das so drüber macht.
Aber das hat bei mir nicht funktioniert, ich mach's so drüber.
Und da läuft er dann, im Prinzip ist es ja sowas ähnliches wie das, was es hier fertig gibt.
Ähm, und da läuft er dann ab und zu mal dieser rote, dieser hier, dieser rote Strich vorbei.
Und wenn der rote Strich vorbeiläuft, erkennt der Line-Sensor, hoho, ich weiche von meinem Pfad ab und geb' nen Signal.
Funktioniert sehr gut.
Äh, was für'n Stromverbrauch hast du?
Bestimmt 300 Kilowatt schon.
Ich kann gerade nicht nachgucken, weil ich das Ding aushab'.
Aber es ist nicht, es ist, äh, nicht so, nicht übermäßig viel eigentlich.
Die ganzen kleinen Controllers, die verbrauchen ja so gut wie nix an Strom.
So, und, äh, funktioniert gut.
Nur mal so nebenbei.
Erkennt er das auch im Deklar?
Also Infrarot-LEDs, die juckt das überhaupt nicht, ob's hell oder dunkel ist.
In meinem Zählerkasten ist immer stock, stockfinster.
Die Ausrichtung ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen egal.
Wirklich, ja.
Da muss man ein bisschen, muss man ein bisschen rumfummeln, bis die Ausrichtung gut funktioniert.
Und was ihr auf jeden Fall einprogrammieren müsst, ist in euren, in euren, äh, ESP-Sketch.
Ähm, oder in euren Arduino-Sketch, aber ich würd'n ESP-2866 oder ein ESP-32 nehmen, einen kleinen dafür.
Und, äh, was ihr auf jeden Fall einprogrammieren müsst, wenn ihr, wenn ihr, wenn ihr sowas hier, äh, dran pappt.
Ähm, der darf nicht auf jedes kleine Signal sofort reagieren.
Also sprich, der darf angehen und dann die nächsten.
Ähm, zehn Sekunden nicht mehr, sonst zählt der nämlich viel zu viel.
Ja, weil dieser, ihr seht ja, dieser rote Strich, der ist nicht wirklich durchgängig.
Der ist dann, da sind ein paar Huppel drauf und dann geht's mal an, dann geht's mal aus.
Also, ihr braucht da so ein bisschen so ne, so ne, so ne, debounce, äh, Logik dahinter.
Also sprich, sobald der Sensor einmal gemeldet hat, dann wird einfach für die nächsten fünf oder zehn Sekunden eben, äh, nichts mehr gemacht.
Und dann misst das Ding ziemlich gut.
So, wir wollten aber weiter einkaufen.
Ähm, also ihr seht, ich hab den ganzen Crap zum größten Teil am Start.
Cooldown, so könnte man das auch nennen.
Global Cooldown.
So, den Mist kaufen wir nicht.
Ähm, Gehäuse haben wir.
Äh, Raspberry Pi Geschiss haben wir auch.
Wish.com, hab ich den Müll überhaupt noch aufgefott?
Huge.
Musik, wieder.
Paras.
Ähm, so.
Also, was wollten wir gucken?
Air Quality Sensor, ne?
DS-Dings.
Da hast du mich nämlich auf ne gute Idee gebracht.
So, so ein Ding wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit mal kaufen.
Was? Gibt's nicht.
Wie?
Moment, es gibt, es gibt was bei AliExpress an Sensor, nicht?
Äh.
Warum findet der SDS 100, hä?
China-Suche.
Excellent.
Du kennst dich doch mit dem Zoll ausmüssen, aber ich kenn mich damit überhaupt nicht aus.
Außer, dass mir schon ein paar Sachen im Zoll gelandet sind, das ist mir, wirklich, ich kenn mich nicht.
Äh, müssen auch Masken bezahlt werden.
Also, ähm, du musst ja eh unter 20 Euro oder 21 Euro musst du eh nix bezahlen.
Ähm, das heißt, wenn du was, wenn das unter 20, 22 Euro ist, inklusive Versand wohlgemerkt, musst du eh nix bezahlen.
Oder 26, irgendwas.
Kleinere Beträge musst du eh nix bezahlen.
Alles da drüber musst du auch keinen Zoll bezahlen, sondern du musst bis, glaub, 150 Euro gesamt werden.
Ja, ja, ja.
Versandkosten zählen mit bis 150 Euro, äh, inklusive Versandkosten musst du die Mehrwertsteuer nochmal obendrauf bezahlen.
Und wenn du erst ab 150 Euro musst du noch Zoll obendrauf bezahlen.
Und ich glaub nicht, dass du über 150 Euro Masken bestellst.
Oh, man weiß ja nie.
So, äh, das sind aber keine Sensor, oder?
Wie sieht denn so, wie sieht denn so ein Sensor überhaupt aus?
Ach, das ist so ein fettes Teil, oder was?
Ich dachte, das ist ein kleiner Mini-Sensor.
Das ist so ein, so ein mega, mega fettes Ding.
Und wie schließt man den an? Per USB?
Na, USB kann ich schon mal an einen ESP32 richtig anschließen.
Zumindest ist der Kram nicht sonderlich teuer.
Könnte man sich, könnte man sich mal einen, einen genehmigen von.
So, was ich, wo ich, wo ich auf jeden Fall noch ein paar brauche, äh, Mini, Mini, äh, OLED-Displays.
Dann nehme ich immer die hier.
S, S...
S, D, 1, 3, ne, wie sind die da?
Da gibt's bestimmt bessere, aber mit denen habe ich insofern ganz gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Die lassen sich total einfach programmieren.
Und, äh, ich habe keine mehr und kleine LCD-Displays zur Anzeige braucht man immer mal wieder.
Das heißt, davon muss ich mir auf jeden Fall nochmal eine Runde bestellen.
Ich glaube, macht auch gar keinen großen Unterschied, was man, was man da bestellt.
Das ist eher alles das Gleiche.
Ja, 12% off.
Wahrscheinlich ist es vollkommen egal, was man bestellen will.
Wir nehmen die, wo der Versand am besten nach Deutschland ist.
Ist das Mega Man?
Ja, klingt irgendwie auch sehr Mega Man-mäßig.
Mega Man-Musik ist auch sowas, die hörst du irgendwie raus.
Welche Temperatursensoren würdest du eigentlich empfehlen, um die Temperatur von der Fläche zu messen?
Zum Beispiel Elektromotor.
Ähm, okay, dann sind die BMP-280 natürlich nicht das Richtige.
Was hältst du von so einem?
Wie gesagt, ich habe den zwar nur im Wasser hängen.
Aber die müssten auch genauso gut funktionieren.
Um, äh, die Temperatur von irgendeiner Platte zu messen.
Also die sind erstens total einfach zu verwenden.
Einfach dranpappen, ja.
Oder am besten wäre natürlich, wenn das Ding ein Loch hat, wo du das reinschieben kannst.
Aber das, wenn es halt kein, wenn es halt kein Loch hat, dann machst du es wahrscheinlich kaputt, wenn du da eins reinmachst.
Das war klar, Alter.
Der Chat wieder.
Ähm, aber die Dinger tun eigentlich gut und sind sehr einfach zu programmieren.
Oder zu benutzen auch.
So, also Displays brauchen wir ein paar Farbe.
Hä?
Achso.
Äh, weiß.
Ja.
Das ist auch das Billigste.
Guck, weiß, weiß, Displays best.
Was haben die für Abmaße?
Stehen da die Abmaße?
Also ich meine jetzt nicht 96 Zoll, sondern was die insgesamt für Abmaße haben.
Steht das da irgendwo?
Oder ist das, ist das unter der Würde vom, vom, vom China-Verkäufer, dass man die Abmaße da draufschreibt?
Wow.
What?
Moment, was zum?
Äh.
Ich check's grad nicht.
Kapiert ihr das?
Ich check, ich, ich, ich, ich erkenne da keine Abmaße.
It's quite simple, really.
Haha, excellent.
Haha.
25 mal 25, wo, wo erkennst du das?
25 mal 25?
Wo steht das?
24,7 mal 27.
24,7.
Ah, jetzt hab ich's kapiert.
Excellent. Chat.
Exquisite-Logik.
27 mal 24, jetzt ist die Frage, was?
Was ist das?
Sind das jetzt Millimeter?
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber man kann sich bei den Einheiten an die Reden nie sicher sein.
Na, Inches können's nicht sein.
24 Zoll ist es deutlich größer.
Aber vielleicht sind das hier irgendeine Ami-, Mini-Ami-Einheit, die ich nicht kenne.
Die Dinger sind aber alle ungefähr gleich groß, ne?
Gucken wir gleich nochmal nach, was die hier so sind.
Abmaße.
23 mal 27.
Ja, die sind alle ungefähr gleich groß.
Da kann man, kann man mal so eins bestellen.
Also eins, ihr wisst ja, eins bestellt man ja prinzipiell eh nicht in China.
Ähm, was ist denn?
30 bis 50 jetzt immer nicht übertreiben, ja.
Und was ist?
Kai...
Kainiano Super Economy Global.
Was ist das denn?
Hab ich noch nie, diese Versandart hab ich noch nie gehört.
Wir nehmen mal AliExpress Standard Shipping.
Wann kommt denn das Ganze dann an?
26 zu 50, ja, das ist okay.
Da kann ich mit leben.
In Millimeter, okay, super.
Ähm.
Ähm, mal schauen wir mal zum Vergleich, was das wo, wie schnell der Versand woanders ist.
Was sagen die hier?
Schon wieder das komische, gleiche.
Oh, das wird ja immer...
Eine Fresse.
Das kommt ja gar nicht mehr an.
26, okay, genau das gleiche.
Dö-dö-dö.
Ähm.
Wo ich mir bei AliExpress immer ein bisschen Schwertu...
Schwertu ist beim...
What the fuck?
Beim Sortieren.
Bei AliExpress, irgendwo...
Gibt's da kostenlosen Versand?
Moment, es gibt
kostenlosen Versand.
Und es kostet genau das gleiche.
Aha, aha, aha.
Und sogar noch
eine Schutzhülle drumherum, die kein Mensch
braucht, aber gut.
White.
Ja, nee, okay, 26 zu 50, kommt alle 26
zu 50 an.
Kommt alle 26 zu 50 an.
Okay, also, schauen wir mal.
Äh, ich wollte gar nicht nach kostenloser
Versand suchen. Eigentlich wollte ich suchen nach
schnellster Versand, aber das krieg ich bei AliExpress
immer nicht hin.
Ähm, okay, AliExpress Standard Shipping
ist okay. Wir brauchen...
Ab wann geht der Standard Shipping
Preis hoch?
Also, ich kauf nicht so viele, ne? Also, keine
Chat, jetzt nicht denken, dass ich jetzt komplett
durchgedreht bin.
Lieferdatum gesehen, ja, 26 zu 5, das ist
okay. Für China-Versand ist es ein Monat,
das...
Das kann, das könnte gut sein, dass es per
Schiff kommt.
Okay, der Versandpreis geht nie hoch.
Für 2,86 Euro kann ich
6000 bestellen.
Oh.
Nee, kann ich nicht. 6000 wird teurer.
1000?
Also, 1000 ist okay.
1000 kann ich bestellen für 2,86 Euro Versandgebühren.
Aber es könnte trotzdem ein bisschen teuer werden.
Könnte trotzdem ein bisschen teuer werden. Wir bleiben
aber bei 10.
Bei diesen kleinen Krams und gerade
bei diesen Displays ist es aus,
also, habe ich persönlich schon die Erfahrung
gemacht, ist es besser,
anstatt, dass man sich 3 oder 5
kauft, man kauft sich wirklich 10er Packs, weil
die sind auch
mal kaputt, wenn sie ankommen.
Also, ich hatte schon Packen, da waren
drei, war quasi
zwei von drei kaputt.
Die AliExpress-Typen
sind zwar immer sehr
hilfsbereit, ich hatte
bei AliExpress wirklich noch nie den Fall,
dass die gesagt haben, piss dich
Alter, gibt nichts mehr. Also,
die Bedenken, die viele
Leute haben, in China zu bestellen,
so nach dem Motto, wenn man Geld bezahlt hat,
ist das Geld weg, kann ich nicht
teilen. Ich meine, ja, wenn es hart auf hart kommt,
hast du keine Chance.
Also, du kannst nicht einfach nach China gehen und sagen, hier,
show me, sonst wie ich
verklage euch. Das funktioniert
natürlich nicht. Aber ich muss sagen,
ich habe bisher mit AliExpress-Händlern
wirklich nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht
und
sogar bessere
Erfahrungen als mit dem PayPal-Käuferschutz.
Also, ich musste
einmal den AliExpress-Käuferschutz
in Anspruch
nehmen und
die waren viel schneller und viel
kundenorientierter
in dem Fall wie PayPal.
Wer ist denn show me, meinst du?
Ja, die spricht man so aus.
Was meinst du denn, wie man
Xiaomi
ausspricht oder wie?
Die heißen tatsächlich show me
show me
Ja, die spricht man wirklich so aus.
Ubuntu
show me
show me, sage ich doch.
Kennst du noch Pong von YouTube, das sagt
irgendetwas.
Pronounciation, wir lassen uns
das jetzt vorlesen.
Text to speech, wir lassen uns das jetzt vorlesen.
Geht anscheinend nicht.
Also, wir bestellen uns.
displays aliexpress standard shipping ach ja ich wollte ja kann auch erzählen
hol dir noch ein was ein mhz 19 b was ist das ein infrarot co2 sensor was
macht man damit jetzt sagt nicht co2 sensen also was wäre der anwendungszweck
war es ist so teuer ist in china auch nicht viel billiger was hältst du von
ihnen displays ja für den jeweiligen handlungszweck ist eine super geschichte
egal ich bestellte erst mal die displays in den einkaufskopf genau fortfahren wo
ist wo ist mein einkauf hallo da ist doch drin zehn stück das heißt
wird aliexpress das glaube ich nicht dass ich bei null euro bin was alle ach so
nein ich will mich jetzt nicht registern
okay was war ich lege mir den kram jetzt erst mal rein genau also oder displays
brauche ich die zähler pack ist gut ich wollte noch der ich wollte noch was
über den aliexpress käuferschutz erzählen du hast noch nichts markiert
was man muss den kram markieren hat echt schon immer so hat es schon immer so ja
okay
gut ich bestelle auch nicht jeden tag im aliexpress vielleicht habe ich schon wieder
verdrängt ich bin mal gespannt wann meine usb schalter da ankommen von aliexpress die
wurden jetzt schon vor ein paar wochen los geschickt die müssten langsam aber sicher
mal da sein zumindest zum thema zum thema käuferschutz bei aliexpress kann ich folgendes
sagen also ich habe mir mal einen rack bestellt bei einer deutschen bringen deutschen versandheit
ist auch egal wo
online wir bei den kunden können sie sich zu sagen da was gebrauchen gerne
so'll safe
sie weiß doch dass sie sich ja auch vielleicht erst an der regel nicht
über paypal bezahlt da gibt's den paypal käuferschutz und paypal käuferschutz ist
relativ wie sie zu benutzen also sprich wenn du nichts bekommst oder wenn es
kaputt ist oder wenn der hersteller nicht reagiert wenn du es zurück schicken
willst was auch immer dann kannst du beim paypal bei paypal kannst du vergisst
die release nicht da mach ich doch und
gemacht und am letzten tag bevor der paypal käuferschutz quasi abgelaufen ist
so dass der dass der shop quasi gezwungen war was zu machen weil ich das
geld von paypal wieder bekommen hätte hat milch der hat mich einen support
mensch von dem shop angerufen hat gesagt hier ich soll das rack behalten weil der
der rückfall der rückversand wäre viel zu teuer
ich wollte zurück schicken weil die glastür kaputt gegangen ist an dem rack
es war so ein kleines zum kleines rack 15 16 he oder so ganz zumindest war das
ein riesenakt und er ging mir voll auf den sack dass ich mich trotzdem so viel
drum kümmern musste obwohl ich paypal käuferschutz verwendet habe so aliexpress
käuferschutz hat viel besser funktioniert ich habe bei aliexpress
was bestellt ich weiß kann aus dem kopf nicht mal was ist was waren das was
habe ich noch bestellt keine ahnung welches china china elektro teile
wahrscheinlich und da haben die gesagt es ist losgeschickt und da habe ich ein
paar wochen gewartet immer unter dieser unter dieser tracking nummer geguckt und
ich weiß nicht warum ich das nicht gemacht habe aber ich weiß nicht warum
ich das nicht gemacht habe aber ich weiß nicht warum ich das nicht gemacht habe
immer stand da diese tracking nummer ist nicht gültig oder ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob da schon diese tracking nummer ist nicht gültig oder oder das
standardmäßige was immer dasteht diese tracking nummer wurde bestellt aber
nichts weiteres bekannt 11 von beiden und da habe ich mich an die aliexpress
käuferschutz gewählt habe sagt hier ich habe eine tracking nummer gekriegt und
die tracking nummer geht irgendwie seit drei wochen schon nicht kam bis jetzt
auch noch nichts an oder hat am gleichen tag
am gleichen tag hat der hersteller auf diesen käuferschutz
geantwortet wahrscheinlich muss der uns wird aber von aliexpress kleine kleine
abmahnung ist raus gleich gelöscht oder so und am gleichen tag haben die
responden haben gesagt ah ja ja ja es gab verzögerungen es wurde jetzt erst
verschickt ob ich noch ein bisschen patient sein kann ja klar kein problem
und es geht heute noch raus oder schickt mir die nummer alles klar hat er mir die
nummer geschickt und die nummer war exakt die gleiche nummer wie vorher die
natürlich auch nicht ginge da kam ich mir ein bisschen
ein bisschen gebetet vor von dem anbieter und da habe ich eine aliexpress
käuferschutz geschrieben hier jungs das ist wieder die gleiche nummer dieses da
hat sie nichts getan oder kommt wieder nichts an so und dann hat aliexpress mir
eine nachricht drauf geschickt also auf diesen käuferschutz request haben gesagt
sie haben den anbieter noch mal kontaktiert und ich soll bis morgen
quasi sagen ob das anbieter noch mal kontaktiert und ich soll bis morgen quasi sagen ob das anbieter noch mal kontaktiert und ich soll bis morgen quasi sagen ob das
ภresolved ist oder nicht und ich habe
nicht reagiert und ich habe irgendwann mein geld zurückgekriegt
also sprich bei paypal ist es so ich muss quasi reagieren sonst ist im
zweifelsfall der shop kriegt das die kohle
bei aliexpress was genau umgedreht ich habe einfach einen tag nichts gemacht hab
mein geld wieder gekriegt
kommen sollte.
Was ist denn das?
Was hast du da gepostet?
Das ist ein iPod, oder?
Das sieht aus wie ein AirPod.
Das sieht aus wie ein AirPod, nur in...
nur in...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist.
AirPod von mich.
Das könnte ein Massagegerät
sein oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest war ich mit dem Käuferschutz
sehr zufrieden von AliExpress
bis jetzt, wo ich den gebraucht hab.
Die einzige Sache
ist nur die, also wenn ihr da
wirklich was bestellt bei AliExpress
und es sollte wirklich mal in die Hose
gehen, also wer da wirklich...
Angenommen, ihr bestellt da wirklich
sagen wir mal einen 3D-Drucker für 400 Euro
oder so, und das geht echt in die Hose.
Ihr habt im Zweifelsfall das
nachsehen, das ist ja logisch.
Ihr könnt nicht nach China gehen,
aber
AliExpress kümmert sich
da drum, also...
Also wenn es Leute gibt, die sagen
dann bestelle ich
lieber...
Dann lasse ich es mir lieber von
Otto bestellen und die
schicken es mir dann zu, so nach dem Motto.
Es ist bescheuert.
Man kann bedenkenlos in China kaufen.
Wirklich komplett
bedenkenlos, zumal
mittlerweile kann man auch ordentlich bezahlen.
Ganz am Anfang, vor
2-3 Jahren, hat man noch
einen Alipay oder wie das Ding, wie ist das?
Alipay?
Hat man noch einen Alipay-Account gebraucht
und der Kram war in Chinesisch.
Da musste man, ich weiß nicht,
hat mal jemand von euch bei AliExpress
mit Alipay bestellt? Das ist
abenteuerlich.
Alipay
gab es damals nur in Chinesisch
und du musstest
quasi Alipay
translaten, um dich anzumelden
und dann, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da Geld
drauf aufgeladen hat. Ich glaube, da konnte
man dann mit Paypal...
Ich glaube, da konnte man mit Kreditkarte
oder Paypal dann aufladen und dann
konnte man mit Alipay... Total, wir.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile kannst
du da aber auch über ordentliche Zahlarten bezahlen.
Guck mal mal, was die hier unterstützen.
Ah, nee, da muss ich mich anmelden. Ach, hier.
Zahlungsmethoden. Visa,
Mastercard, keine Ahnung.
Leider kein Paypal. Wäre
cool, hätten die noch Paypal, aber
Kreditkarte
geht auch.
Paypal ist recht selten.
In München wird in vielen Gasthäusern und Shops Alipay
akzeptiert. Wundert mich nicht.
Da sind ja auch viele Touristen
aus China.
Wie suchst du deine Waren aus, ohne
Fälschungen zu kaufen? Gar nicht.
Gar nicht. Also, keine Chance.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass diese Dinger im Prinzip
alles China-Ware sind. Auch welche,
die du hier kaufst.
Also von so billig Elektronik-Kram,
das ist eh alles China-Fake.
Oder China-Kram.
Macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wo man sich halt auch nicht drauf verlassen darf, ist,
wenn man sich beispielsweise eine
WLAN-Steckdose oder irgendwie sowas bestellt,
die sind Meister da drin,
jegliche Prüfzeichen aufzudrucken,
ohne dass das Ding
einmal in seinem Leben
irgendeine Prüfstelle gesehen hat.
Also, das ist auch eine Sache,
da bin ich ein bisschen skeptisch.
Da kaufe ich bei AliExpress eigentlich
nix
Sachen, die der an
230 Volt an die Steckdose
anschließt.
Das ist mir nix bei den meisten
AliExpress.
Aber so ganze Elektronik,
die kleinen Elektronik-Dinger,
was soll da passieren?
Das sind 3,3 oder 5 Volt.
Würdest du von AliExpress ein Arduino kaufen?
Ja, warum nicht?
Wenn es sich preislich lohnt.
So, auch wieder Chrono-Trigger-Musik.
Das Spiel hat wirklich einen der besten Soundtracks,
die es je gibt.
Du hast doch die Steckdosen-Leisten bestellt, ja?
Aber die habe ich
nicht bei AliExpress, sondern bei Amazon bestellt.
Die Chrono-Trigger-Leisten.
Kogik-Steckdosen-Leiste.
Die hier.
Die gibt es nicht mehr.
Und die heißt auch irgendwie nicht mal Kogik.
Sondern heißt auf einmal
Smalux.
Warum auch immer.
Ja, Kogik.
Kogik, ne, das ist aber die falsche.
Das ist die Fake.
Das ist die Fake-Kogik-Leiste.
Die, die viel zu teuer ist.
Die hier war richtig gut.
Wisst ihr noch, was die gekostet hat damals bei Amazon?
Ich glaube 29 Euro oder so.
Und 29 Euro für eine Steckdosen-Leiste,
die man flashen kann
und quasi für 29 Euro
eine IP-Steckdosen-Leiste bekommt
mit Web-Interface,
mit vier Schaltern und USB
ist preis-leistungsmäßig
absolut top.
Aber die gibt es anscheinend
nicht mehr.
Guck mal, ob es die
bei AliExpress gibt.
Ah.
Ja, aber auch nur die mit 3. Die wollen wir nicht.
Die ist viel zu teuer. Viel zu teuer.
Viel zu crappy alles.
Wir wollen die mit 4 Steckern
und 4x USB.
Smart Plug.
Und nicht das, was der Chat
jetzt gleich wieder hier hat.
EU.
Wir suchen einfach Steckdosen-Leiste.
Das ist keine Leiste.
Deswegen habe ich extra eine Leiste gesucht.
Aber brauche ich keine.
Ich habe ja noch die Kogik-Leiste.
Also wer sich fragt,
wie das Ding im Einsatz aussieht.
Ich habe das ja hier
in dem einen Video gezeigt.
Ja.
Das ist die Steckdosen-Leiste.
4x USB.
4x ganz normaler Anschluss.
Und das Beste daran ist halt,
dass man die,
wo zeige ich es denn hier,
dass man die über das Web-Interface steuern kann.
Die Steckdosen-Leiste.
Weiß gar nicht, ob ich mal zeige.
Ja, guckt hier. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
1, 2, 3, 4 und USB ist 5.
Und das ist halt nice.
Ja.
Man hat im Endeffekt eine IP-Steckdosen-Leiste für 29 Euro.
Hast du eine Kamera, Auto
mit Bewegungsmelder?
Da ist kein Bewegungsmelder dran.
Also, was habe ich gesagt?
Ich brauche noch Relays.
Ich muss mal in meinen Einkaufszettel kurz gucken.
Ich muss mal rauslöschen,
was ich schon habe.
Relays brauche ich noch.
Relays.
Ähm.
Was brauche ich denn für welche?
12 Volt reicht nicht.
Wobei, das ist doch die Spannung,
ähm,
äh,
für den, was man anschließen kann
zum Schalten, oder?
5 Volt ist für den ESP okay.
Also, warum ich, ich brauche eigentlich,
so Fette brauche ich nicht.
Ich brauche kleine, allerdings schon fertig montiert.
Sowas, sowas hier brauche ich genau.
Okay, schaltet was?
Bis zu?
Also,
5 Volt für den Input.
Oh, die blauen
Billig-Relays hattest du mal alle Schrott.
Echt? Okay.
Ich hätte mir jetzt davon auch ein 10er-Pack bestellt.
Ähm.
Und die schalten bis zu,
also, ich würde da im Leben
äh, kein normaler
Strom aus der Steckdose da,
also, ich würde da im,
ich würde da im Leben keine 230 Volt dran anschließen.
Also,
ich verwende das für was, was
im Endeffekt, lass mal überlegen,
24,
24 Volt höchstens hat.
Oder 60, oder 48?
Also, entweder 24
oder 48. Also,
ich gehe da garantiert nicht mit, mit
aus der Steckdose dran.
Die Losen waren komplett Mist, okay.
Na,
ich probiere es mal aus. Oh ja, genau!
Hier, sehr gut.
Wer, wer hat es gefunden?
Hier, der
Beta Dota Meta.
Ja, genau, das ist
exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste.
Was man daran auch wieder schön sieht, ist,
ich zeige es euch mal kurz,
was man daran auch wieder schön sieht, ist,
dass die ganzen China-Dinger
reprinten ohne Ende. Das ist exakt die gleiche
Steckdosenleiste. Bei mir stand da
noch Cogeek drauf, da steht jetzt
Ofo,
Aofo drauf, aber
es ist exakt,
ihr habt es ja gesehen,
es ist exakt die gleiche China-
Steckdosenleiste.
Na, ihr seht, es ist exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste.
Bei mir steht Cogeek drauf, hier steht
Aofo drauf, ist genau das gleiche
Kram. Ähm,
33 Euro
lohnt sich. Ähm,
mit was hast du die geflasht, wofür braucht man eine
Steckdosenleiste mit WLAN?
Eine Steckdosenleiste mit WLAN, äh,
brauchst du, ich weiß, klingt jetzt
doof, brauchst du immer dann, wenn du
Remote, also ohne, dass du irgendwie
davorstehst, was an- und ausschalten willst.
Das kann alles mögliche sein.
Sei es ein Wäschetrockner, den du ausschalten
willst, oder dass du morgens deine Kaffeemaschine
einschalten willst, oder dass
du, äh,
dass deine Konsole im Standby
nicht so viel zieht, alles mögliche.
Für was man halt sonst auch, äh,
Steckdosenleisten
mit Schalter verwendet.
Also ich hab zum Beispiel
jetzt eine hier neben mir liegen, da ist der,
mein neuer, die kleine Serverkiste
dran.
Und, ähm, ein paar Ladegeräte
für
ein Raspberry ist dran, die, äh,
Serverkiste, die, die
2 HE,
2 HE Serverkiste ist dran, und
ein paar Ladegeräte für,
also einen Mini-USB und
einen Lightning für, äh,
äh, Geräteladen.
So, und der Vorteil davon ist,
dass man zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt irgendwie
was hängt davon
und nicht funktioniert, warte mal, ich bin grad voll doof
und mein Kabel gefahren, da kann ich ohne,
dass ich hinlaufen muss, was jetzt in dem Fall natürlich
doof ist, weil,
der steht hinter mir, ja,
äh, kann ich zum Beispiel, oder könnte ich zum Beispiel
den Server in meinem Serverraum neu, neu starten
oder den Router neu starten, das
DSL-Modem neu starten, ohne dass ich hinlaufen muss.
Wenn du zum Beispiel das DSL-Modem
im Keller hast, sag mal, du hast ne Fritz-Box
im Keller, du hast ne, ne, ne, ne,
Unity-Media-Box im Keller,
nen WLAN, nen WLAN-Accesspoint
und,
ach, keine Ahnung, noch irgendwas,
den Trockner, so,
und die kannst du dann remote ein- und ausschalten.
Und das ist das, was normalerweise
unter dem, unter dem Betriff
IP-Steckdose läuft,
und ne IP-Steckdose, ne richtig
gute, ordentliche, da geht ab 300 Euro
los.
Und hier kriegst du quasi ne billige
IP-Steckdose für 29 Euro,
für 33 Euro, das ist, das ist top.
Ähm,
warum man das flasht, ist ganz einfach,
damit man das offline benutzen kann, weil ich will ja
keine China-Cloud verwenden müssen,
ähm, dafür,
dass ich meine Steckdosenleiste ein- und ausschalten
kann. Wie genau, richtig,
Eiskräuter. Damit, damit man keine
China-Cloud braucht, dass sie mehr Funktionen hat,
und, äh, wie gesagt, diese
Tasmota-Geschichte ist wirklich sehr
angenehm.
Man sieht's ja auch hier, man kann jede Menge Sachen
einstellen, ähm,
und man kann die Steckdosenleiste ein- und
ausschalten über das Webinterface, und natürlich
nicht nur über das Webinterface,
ähm, sondern hat, man kann natürlich auch das
von seiner Heimautomatisierung damit
steuern.
Das ist kein Problem. Dann funktioniert,
das ist wirklich, wenn man's einmal, wenn man's einmal gemacht hat,
es ist total einfach.
Wir haben's ja sogar im Livestream gemacht.
Wir haben's ja sogar im Livestream gemacht, also wenn irgendeiner
den Livestream sucht, der Sibaro
hat's bestimmt noch im Archiv.
Warum braucht man weitere Funktionen auf
einer Steckdosenleiste? Wie gesagt, dass man die
Steckdosenleiste an- und ausschalten kann
übers Netzwerk.
Ohne, dass man eine
China-Cloud braucht.
Das geht ja normalerweise nicht.
Ach ja, genau. Musstest du zum
Löten flashen, äh, zum, zum Flashen
löten? Nein, musste ich nicht.
Äh, hast du schon mal was mit OpenHub gemacht?
Nee, ich nehm Home Assistant.
Wir haben das da mitgemacht.
Tuya Convert.
Noch mit der alten Version. Wir haben's noch mit der
alten Version gemacht, aber
es gibt jetzt eine neue Version, die auch bei
neueren Geräten
funktioniert. Wir haben's da
mitgemacht.
Sibaro, weißt du zufällig,
äh, welcher Stream im Archiv das ist,
wo wir die Steckdosenleiste geflasht haben?
Nee, oder?
Wahrscheinlich aus dem Stehgreif nicht.
Home Lords Steckdosenleiste.
Ah!
Das ist bestimmt nur ein Clip, ne?
Das ist, okay, das ist nur ein Clip.
Ah ja, excellent, excellent
auf Russisch, natürlich.
Alles klar. Wollt schon immer,
Wollt schon immer, dass mein Twitch auf Russisch
ist.
Äh, okay, also, der,
das ist schon zu lange her. Guck mal,
das ist, ähm,
fast ein Jahr her, wo wir das gemacht
haben. Dreivierteljahr.
Aber wir haben's noch im Archiv. Wir haben's noch
irgendwo im Archiv. Also, wenn's einen interessiert,
könnt ihr im Archiv gucken. Archiv
gibt's hier freundlicherweise
vom Sibaro gepflegt.
Ja, da gibt's Google Drive mit
allen Stream-Aufzeichnungen.
Also, wir wissen's doch. Wow, wow, wow,
ah!
Ich will meine eigenen Streams nicht runterladen.
Also, Stream war vom,
hab ich schon wieder vergessen. Von wann war
das denn? Wir hatten's doch
gerade.
Äh, wie hab ich
das, wie hab ich das eben
klein gekriegt?
Hier.
19. Juni war das.
Warte mal, Januar, April,
Juni.
Hier.
Da.
Da ist es doch.
Guck ich Steckdosenleiste flashen.
Da hat der Sibaro das auch gerade rausgefunden.
Sibaro hat gerade ein Link geschickt
hier.
Da ist der Stream, wo wir die Steckdosenleiste geflasht haben.
Ähm,
das haben wir aber noch mit dem alten Tuya Convert
gemacht, das wahrscheinlich
bei diesen Steckdosenleisten immer noch funktionieren
wird. Wir haben das hier mitgemacht. Das ist,
ihr werdet's im Stream sehen, das ist wirklich
Einfach Raspberry Pi mit dem Skript drauf
starten und fertig ist es.
Gelaufen ist es.
Ja, es gibt ein neues Tuya Convert, was auch
jetzt mit den gepatchten Geräten
funktioniert. Ne, IOProker
verwende ich nicht.
Hab ich gerade eben richtig gesehen, dass der Eax
im Chat war?
Oder war das nur im Stream gerade,
wo ich die Aufzeichnung
gesehen hab? Ja, es gibt
ein neues Tuya Convert. So.
So, also, dann holen wir uns noch mal ein paar Relays
hiervon. Was kann man
dazu bieten? AliExpress Standard Shipping
20.05.
Kostet das mehr?
Wow!
AliExpress, was ist mit euch
los? Was, was, was kosten?
Was kosten denn die Dinger?
Was kosten die bei Amazon.de?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Stück
8 Euro. Geht doch
eigentlich. Eigentlich kann man bei Amazon bestellen.
Schau mal auf Ebay. Ne, Ebay
kauf ich nix. Ebay hab ich irgendwie
voll die Ableitung dagegen.
Ebay Woodface, alter.
Ebay mag ich nicht.
Oh, guck mal, kostenloser Versand.
Excellent.
Äh, hallo?
Kostenloser Versand.
11.06.
Wisst ihr, wohin gibt's kostenlosen Versand?
7.
Okay.
Das lohnt sich natürlich. Das ist dann schon mal ne ganze Ecke
billiger. Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Jetzt. Komm, ich kaufe mal so ne billig
Variante hier.
Warum kostet hier der Versand mit
Yanwen Economy
Air Mail
27 und da ist es
kostenlos, obwohl es genau der
gleiche Crap ist.
Ah gut, da kostet das Relay ein bisschen mehr.
Aber trotzdem lohnt sich, lohnt sich trotzdem nicht.
Dann kaufen wir 6 Stück
hiervon. In den Einkaufswagen.
Wenn man eine Hütte
abbrennt, musst du erklären, was für China-Produkte drin sind.
Das Gute daran ist ja, ich benutze die
nirgendswo, wo es großartig brennt.
Also wo es großartig brennen kann.
Wieso hast du so viele YouTube-Apps offen?
Weil das noch die YouTube-Session
ist von Sonntag.
Wo wir uns Videos angeguckt haben.
Schon ein Projekt für die Teile?
Ja, deswegen bestelle ich sie.
Ich habe ja wie gesagt meine Tür-Gegensprecheranlage
jetzt abgecradet.
Also ich habe
ein ESP32
eingebaut in das Telefon.
Gegensprecheranlagen-Telefon.
Und das checkt, wenn es klingelt.
Und das checkt, wenn der Hörer abgenommen wird.
Die einzige Sache ist,
das Netzteil für die Tür-Gegensprecheranlage
hat
maximal
1,3 Ampere.
Und für zwei
Gegensprecheranlagen-Telefon
plus meine
also ich habe mir so eine Box gekauft,
mit der ich dann die
Gegensprecheranlage
mit meinem
SIP-Telefon verbinden kann.
Und
mit diesen drei Geräten dran
reichen die 1,3 Ampere
von dem Klingelnetzteil
nicht aus.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
nachdem ich jetzt rauskriege,
an welchen Hörer jemand ran geht
und ob es klingelt,
dann kann ich einfach mit einem Relay
einen der anderen Geräte ausschalten
und schon ist
alles wieder okay.
Also sprich, sobald einer
geklingelt hat
und einer an das Telefon geht,
schalte ich einfach eines der anderen zwei Geräte
mit dem Relay aus.
Und dann
packt es das Netzteil wieder.
So habe ich mir das zumindest gedacht.
Ich hoffe das funktioniert.
Konnte mal an der Sache folgen,
was ich jetzt da vor mich hingestammelt habe.
Hast du einen
Romantik-Modus?
Ne, ich habe kaum Beleuchtung im Smart Home drin.
Ich habe kaum Beleuchtung.
Stimmt, was hat ein Gearbest so zu bieten?
Da haben wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt.
Wurde bisher nicht so oft gebraucht.
Zumindest nicht, da ist schon was dran.
Zumindest nicht so oft, dass ich auf die Idee gekommen wäre,
da irgendwelche Beleuchtung
einzubauen.
Mal zur Knock-Off-Logo.
Wie war das?
AliExpress sind die Chinesen, ne?
Waren Banggood die Inder
oder war Gearbest die Inder?
Oder sind das alles Chinesen?
Ich bilde mir ein...
Banggood war doch Indien, oder?
Oder war Banggood auch China?
Alles Chinesen?
Na gut.
Dann alles Chinesen.
Ich dachte einer von diesen drei,
das sind ja so die drei größten,
ich dachte einer von diesen drei Shops
wären Inder gewesen.
Ist ja auch egal.
So, also.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Relays.
Jetzt haben wir
unsere LEDs.
Vor allem ist das halt alles ultra billig.
Wir bezahlen jetzt
22 Euro am Ende dafür.
Das war nix großartig.
So, was brauchen wir sonst noch schönes?
Ich muss mal in meine Einkaufsliste reingehen.
Ich brauche noch ein paar bunte
Netzwerkkabel.
Aber die kaufe ich, glaube ich, bei Amazon.
Relays habe ich.
Ich könnte mal gucken,
haben die 12 Volt DC
zu USB?
Konverter
haben die welche?
RJ45 Kabel.
Ne, ne, ne.
Sowas, sowas
hier.
Kannst du auch Netzwerkkabel,
Kabelscheune.
Ich hätte die jetzt einfach bei Amazon gekauft.
Machst du dann selbst,
da kaufe ich mir fertige.
Meine letzten eigenen Patch
und Grimm Versuche gab es ja auf Twitter zu sehen.
Kabel,
Kabelscheune.
Gucken wir mal,
gucken wir gleich.
Mal gucken, ob die hier,
weil ich habe
ein 12 Volt Netzteil im Keller.
Das passt auch, das kommt auch durch das Leerrohr
raus.
Aber
da müssen die Tablets dran
zum Laden.
Und die Tablets sind ja USB.
An die Tablets kann ich nicht einfach,
ich kann nicht einfach einen USB Stecker an die 12 Volt machen.
Dann brennt mir das Tablet durch.
Es gibt doch bestimmt einen 12 Volt auf USB Stecker.
Wo dann 5 Volt rauskommen.
Muss es doch geben.
Also ich weiß, dass es das gibt, weil das habe ich auch.
Aber ich brauche noch welche.
Im Endeffekt wahrscheinlich
sowas hier, aber
ich brauche ein Display und solche Spielereien.
Ja im Prinzip
sowas ähnliches, wie was
im Auto reinkommt, bloß halt kleiner.
Das sieht ja billig aus.
Guck mal, das bricht schon fast ab.
Kauf so ein Ding, baust du aus. Nein.
Ich kaufe das fertig. Wenn ich groß rumbauen müsste,
dann könnte ich es auch gleich selbst machen.
Weil DC zu DC
Konverter habe ich alle möglichen Varianten.
Da müsste ich
dann auf der einen Seite einfach nur ein USB Kabel dran machen.
USB Kabel anschließen ist ja
kein Ding. Du musst ja, wenn du nur Strom
haben willst, musst du ja nur die 2 passenden
Arme vom USB Kabel anschließen.
Was ist das für Musik?
Das war
Metroid Musik.
Sowas da, genau.
Sowas da sieht doch gut aus.
Ja sowas brauche ich.
Sowas will ich haben.
Sowas brauche ich.
Welche USB Netzteile nimmst du?
Keine.
Oder was meinst du?
Kennt jemand von euch
ein gutes
Labornetzteil?
Also ein günstiges
Labornetzteil.
Sagen wir mal so unter 100 Euro.
Wo man
so mit Kleinkram, Elektronikkram
auskommt. Also irgendwas
von 3,3
Volt bis
48 oder so.
Gibt es da gescheite Sachen?
Das sieht doch cool aus in dem Gebiet.
Aber ich hätte mir letztens gewünscht, ich hätte eins da.
Aber ohne einen ESP32 zu betreiben.
Ähhhhh
Lass mal überlegen.
Wie habe ich denn den jetzt gerade angeschlossen?
Den, also den ESP32
Ähm
Der hier jetzt an der
Gegensprechanlage ist. Der ist an so einem
Konverter, an so einem ähnlichen Konverter hier dran.
Ähm unten im Keller
ist ein 12 Volt Netzteil. Das geht dann durch den
Kabelkanal quasi
an die Gegensprecher, also an das Telefon.
Und in der Dose hinter dem Telefon
an der Wand ist ja der eine ESP32
drin. Und da ist so ein
12 Volt auf USB Konverter.
Da steckt der gerade dran.
Ich benutze keine extra USB Netzteile.
Die ESP's
brauchen so wenig.
Irgendwas mit
USB und gut ist, die laufen überall
dran.
Empfehlung für Sie, ja. Irgendwelche
Pumpen. Also die sind
nicht schlecht die Dinger. Was kostet sowas bei Amazon?
12 Volt
Konverter
USB
Na gut.
Was haben wir? 12 Volt.
Bis zu wahrscheinlich 24 oder so.
Ja.
Sowas da.
Wow.
Oh. Das ist aber viel zu teuer.
Genau sowas.
Genau sowas suche ich. Dann nehme ich lieber den von
AliExpress.
So einzelne Dinge habe ich genug da.
Das heißt eigentlich bräuchte ich
den gar nicht. Das ist bloß
die Komfort
Variante, dass ich das USB
Kabel nicht aufschneiden muss.
Komm ich bestelle die einfach bei AliExpress.
174 ist doch ok.
174 sieht schön
klein und kompakt aus.
Input 6-24 Volt.
Ausgang USB
ähm
5 Volt 3. Top.
Das ist genau das was ich brauche.
Und das ganze machen wir
auch per AliExpress.
Standard Shipping.
Was hältst du von KNX?
Hausautomatisierung habe ich noch nichts mitgemacht.
Aber was kostet denn das andere?
Tracking, Tracking. Das ist das einzige
mit Tracking.
Was ist der Vorteil gegenüber KNX?
Gegenüber ähm
Sachen über äh
C-Wave?
Wahrscheinlich, dass es über Kabel
geht, ne? Geh mal stark von aus.
Was?
Immer 4 Cents.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Komm, weißt du was, das ist so billig.
Komm, dann bestellen wir mal 10 Stück von.
Kostet ja so gut wie nix. Einkaufswagen. Easy.
Bam. Next.
Aber wie viel sind wir denn jetzt hier gerade?
Ah ja, da geht noch ein bisschen was.
Da kann man
noch ein bisschen Kleinkram kaufen.
Was wir so brauchen.
Äh, wofür brauchst du das?
Ähm
Ich hab die
Das ist das Telefon von meiner Tür Gegensprecher
Lage. Da habe ich einen Controller drin, der
checkt, wann das ganze klingelt. Und neben
dem Telefon habe ich, da habe ich
oben und unten ein Tablet hängen. Ich habe doch
hier Post, Image
Warum
vergisst der, warum
vergisst das Ding immer
Post, Image, ah hier. Warum vergisst
das Ding immer meine Bilder?
Da hatten wir es doch, genau. So.
Und da
was auch immer.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt geht's. Ähm
Da sieht man es.
Da kommen aktuell aus dem Keller 12 Volt
rauf, von so einem, von einem ganz normalen
Netzteil. Und ähm
Da innen drin ist ein ESP32
der muss versorgt werden, mit 5 Volt USB.
Man könnte es, wenn man 3,3
Volt hätte, würde das auch funktionieren, weil man kann
den auch direkt an den Input Pinsch legen.
Und ich muss die Tablets laden.
Und aktuell habe ich da halt,
dahinter, so einen
so ein Teil.
Moment.
So, so ein ähnliches Teil
wie das hier habe ich dahinter.
Hier kommt, hier kommt die 12 Volt Input rein
und außen kommt USB raus.
Was macht das Tablet da?
Ähm, das zeigt mir die Kamera an vom Hof
und vom, vom, vom ähm
von der Haustür, wenn's
klingelt.
Also sprich, hier dahinter ist ein Mikrocontroller
der checkt, wenn es klingelt.
Und wenn es klingelt, macht der das Tablet
an.
Und auf dem Tablet läuft, also macht
er dann den Browser auf.
Und da sehe ich dann die Eingangstür und den Hof.
Das heißt, wenn ich, wenn ich
an der Gegensprechanlage ankomme,
habe ich schon gleich den Blick drauf,
ah, wer ist denn da?
Dann sehe ich, es ist der DHL-Mann, dann sage ich, ja, ich komme runter.
Oder ich sehe, es ist mein Vater, dann sage ich,
ah, ne, ich bin nicht da.
Ähm,
also insofern ist das ganz praktisch.
Das ist,
ja, richtig.
Hast du ein Repo
für deinen Linux-Dot? Falls ja, habe ich.
Aber da ist die, das ist, das ist
übrigens keine Polybar.
Das ist keine Polybar.
Ähm, was hatten wir denn hier mal angelegt?
Action-Test-Repo, das gibt es überhaupt nicht mehr.
Dot, Dot-Files.
Ähm,
aber ich habe die
Konfig für die Statusleiste habe ich drinnen.
Die ist da.
Da ist die Konfig für die
Statusleiste.
Aber wie gesagt, keine Polybar.
Kommt morgen auch wieder ein Stream, mal gucken, mal gucken.
So, also den Kram haben wir
auch. Was braucht man denn sonst noch Schönes?
Ich gehe auch gleich,
Leute, ich gehe gleich nochmal die Fragen durch,
die ich vielleicht übersehen habe. Ich habe die ja alle mitgelockt.
MonkaTos.
Ähm,
mal eine Frage an die Elektrotechnikers
hier unter uns.
Kann man,
ich habe da echt keine Ahnung
von, vielleicht frage ich jetzt,
was total, was total Bescheuertes,
ne?
Ich kenne mich da nur wirklich sehr rudimentär aus.
Ich kann ein paar kleine Schaltungen
zusammenpasteln,
ich kann ein bisschen
Vorwiderstand-Kram ausrechnen,
aber ich beabte echt
keinen Plan von Elektrotechnik-Zeug.
Ähm, das war nur eine Frage an euch,
falls wir hier welche haben, die ich damit auskenne.
Kann man
aus 12
Volt AC
verlässlich
3,3 oder 5
Volt DC machen,
mit maximal 150 Milliampere?
Was ich brauche.
Für die, für die Controller.
Ich habe da nämlich schon mal gesucht,
es gibt nichts Fertiges.
Und wenn es nichts Fertiges gibt,
oder ich habe nichts gefunden,
dann ist es entweder die Sache,
ich suche nach dem Falschen,
oder aber,
das geht nicht richtig.
Full Bridge Rectifier.
Ne, ich will die Ampere nicht,
ich will die nicht begrenzen,
ich weiß nur, dass mein Controller
nicht mehr als 150 Milliampere ganz kurz braucht.
Okay, also sag mal,
nach was, nach was soll ich suchen?
Nach was soll ich suchen?
Ihr müsst mir das ein bisschen noob, noob
mäßig erklären.
Alles in einem wirst du das nicht finden, ist ja sehr
speziell. Okay, also warum ich das machen will,
werde ich euch mal kurz erklären.
Und zwar, ich habe als Gegensprechanlage
dieses Ding hier.
Ähm, und dabei
ist, wie gesagt, zwei Telefone,
Gegensprechanlage, so, und dabei ist
folgendes Netzteil mit
dabei, das da.
Dieses Netzteil ist
dabei, so, und was man hier sieht ist,
wenn ich jetzt nicht total noobig bin und das
Ganze, ähm,
richtig erkenne,
hier oben ist der Input, da gehe ich nicht ran,
ja, zeige ich euch gleich, da gehe ich nicht ran.
Es gibt hier unten
Output 12V
AC.
Ist das die Grund auf Mana?
Ha! Auch richtig geile Musik.
Ähm, es gibt
hier einmal 12V
AC, Plus, Minus, wobei Plus, Minus
gibt es ja bei AC nicht wirklich, ne?
Ähm, hier einmal und hier einmal.
Man hat quasi zwei Ausgänge
12V AC. Und ich habe mir überlegt,
nachdem das Netzteil schon unten
eingebaut ist, und das Kabel
ja schon da ist, ich könnte mir da
einfach nochmal, ähm,
ein bisschen was abzwacken
für einen ESP32.
Alles in einem. Oh, guck mal hier,
das Swaggy, Swaggy Mac Awesome Live.
Das kopiere ich mir.
Das gucke ich mir jetzt mal an.
Wie hast du, wie hast du das
jetzt so schnell gefunden?
Ich habe nach allem möglichen gesucht.
Okay, also was macht das? Ich habe wirklich
nach allen möglichen Kombinationen auf Amazon gesucht,
aber wahrscheinlich liegt es einfach daran,
dass ich keine Ahnung habe, nach was ich genau suchen muss.
Hab AC, DC
Bug Converter gesucht. Jetzt danach habe ich garantiert
nicht gesucht.
Danach habe ich bestimmt nicht gesucht.
Warum streamst du eigentlich in 1080p, 48 FPS?
Das liegt daran,
weil ich ja hauptsächlich hier Desktop
Geschichten streame in letzter Zeit.
Das heißt, 180p ist wichtig,
dass es scharf ist und 48 FPS,
weil es flüssiger ist als
30 FPS und nicht so viel,
äh,
naja, bei gleicher Bandbreite schärfer aussieht
und flüssiger ist.
Also flüssiger als 30
und, ähm, schärfer
bei gleicher Bandbreite wie 60.
Wahrscheinlich macht es aber
sichtbar kaum einen Unterschied.
Overwatch streamen ganz
viele in, äh, ich glaube
948,
900,
ich sag jetzt mal irgendwas,
936p mit 48 FPS
oder so, so ganz scheppes Zeug.
Weil Overwatch halt relativ viel
Kamerabewegung hat.
Kannst du die Bitrate nicht auf 8 Mbit setzen?
Doch kann ich, aber da kann es kaum einer gucken.
Weil wir doch in Deutschland sind
und das Internet hier suckt.
Okay, sowas brauche ich also.
10 Euro, das ist doch auch okay.
Soll ich, ähm, warte mal,
wir hatten das hier, ähm,
genau, also Swaggy
Macawesome und hier der Cooper
1338, die kennen sich da ja wohl aus.
Habe ich noch mal eine Frage,
ähm, soll ich das
noch irgendwie in irgendeine Kiste
machen oder so? Also
passiert da was, wenn man dran greift?
Also, dass mir nichts passiert, ist klar.
Bei
24 Volt und bei,
aber geht es kaputt, wenn ich da dran greife?
Soll ich das noch in irgendeine Kiste
stecken? Oder irgendwie so
irgendwie einen fetten, fetten Schrumpfschlauch drum
rum machen?
Ich mache einen fetten Schrumpfschlauch
drum. Ich habe mir nämlich
erst letztens zwei, zwei, irgendwie
zwei Meter Schrumpfschleuchel gekauft.
Die, die mache ich da einfach
drum und, und puste mal drüber mit der
Heißluft, mit dem Heißluftding und dann ist
das
ist das schön dicht.
Das, dann mache ich das so, Leute.
So, so, so. Excellent. Siehste, Leute,
die ganzen Subscriber heute haben sich
schon wieder gelohnt. Der IQ des Chats
ist so hoch, dass ich jetzt Sachen
gefunden habe, die ich vorher überhaupt nicht
wusste, dass sie existieren.
Du würdest eine Kiste mit Schlitzen drucken.
Wäre auch eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Ich muss gerade mal gucken, ob ich irgendwelche
Subs übersehen habe.
Ne, zum Glück nicht.
Handy-Primers.
Ja, sehr, sehr schön. Das kaufen wir
doch gleich auch nochmal in den Einkaufswagen. Easy.
Davon kaufe ich mal nur einen.
Leute, ich habe offiziell
zum ersten Mal heute gegen meine
mindestens drei Kaufen-Regel verstoßen,
aber ich brauche davon höchstens einen.
Ever. So nach dem Motto.
Und, ähm,
warum soll ich 30 Euro umsonst,
warum soll ich 20 Euro mehr ausgeben?
So, sehr schön. Da haben wir
doch wieder was.
Warum möchte Amazon, dass ich mir
dass ich mir Mama Mia
Here We Go Again angucke?
Ich habe absolut
kein Interesse, mir das anzugucken.
Null.
Alarm.
Aber was, wenn der eine beim Einbauen
kaputt geht und du einen Ersatz brauchst?
Ja. Na, komm.
Komm, zwei. Zwei reichen aber.
Zwei reichen aber wirklich.
Zwei, mehr brauche ich nicht.
So, haben wir das? Was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Zeige ich mal her, was habe ich hier noch?
Netzwerkkabel müssen wir noch kaufen, klar.
Ähm, wie lange haben wir das?
Haben wir das? Haben wir...
Äh, bei der Gelegenheit können wir gerade mal
bei Amazon gucken, ob
es mal wieder schöne
IP66
so Boxen gibt.
Schöne kleine.
So welche da. So sieht das doch hübsch.
So was, so
wasserdichte Dinge oder zumindest
regendichte Dinge, also kann man immer mal gebrauchen.
Ich nehme den kleinen.
Zum Beispiel, was bei mir
noch ansteht ist,
ähm, ähm,
eingangs am
Hoftor, da habe ich schon einen Schalter
installiert, der erkennt, wenn das Hof
auf und zu geht.
Aber, ähm,
da ist noch kein Controller an dem.
Da hängt einfach nur der Schalter.
Das heißt, ich bestelle mir nochmal
zwei IP66 Dosen.
Das lohnt sich
auf jeden Fall. Die kann man immer gebrauchen.
Kann man eigentlich fast nie genug haben, aber
zwei Stück reicht.
So, ähm,
so, was wollte ich jetzt noch gucken?
Genau, Netzwerkkabel. Ähm,
eigentlich habe ich, also, was habt ihr gesagt?
Kabelmeister.
Eine Kabelscheune. Die Sache ist die,
ich bestelle es, glaube ich, trotzdem lieber bei Amazon.
Preislich nimmt es sich wahrscheinlich nicht so viel.
Und,
da ist der Versand drin
bei Amazon.
Hier ist wahrscheinlich nicht der Versand drin.
Ich brauche, ich will eigentlich nur
eine bunte
Netzwerkkabel.
Was gibt es? Bunte?
Netzstrumpfhose. Ah.
Sowas da. Genau.
Sowas da will ich haben im Endeffekt.
Was ist das denn?
0,5 Meter.
Und wie viel
Stück? Wie viel sind das?
Zehn, zehn.
Ist ganz schön teuer, oder? Warum
bunt? Ähm, ich habe,
weil ich noch Graue genug
habe, ich wollte ein paar bunte
und ich habe halt gehofft, man kann,
weil es ein bisschen billiger ist,
ähm,
dass ich die ein bisschen so, je nachdem, was ich sie verwende,
halt, äh,
ein bisschen gruppieren kann.
Okay, also
was haben die da zu bieten? Kabelscheune.
Warten wir mal, was hatten die da?
Okay, also Patchkabel
RJ45.
Ganz ehrlich, bei der Länge ist mir das
vollkommen egal. Das kann mal
K5E sein. So.
Ähm, ist Mario Kart?
Ach nee.
Äh, Pferderennen.
Okay, sagen wir mal,
wir wollen, wir wollen ein
rotes, ein blaues und gelb.
Sehr gut.
Magenta. Die Magenta-DNA.
Äh,
so fünf Stück.
Okay, das ist deutlich günstiger
als bei, bei Amazon.
Guck mal, bei Amazon wollen die für zehn
Stück 13 Euro haben.
Äh, hier kosten zehn Stück
6,90.
Das ist, das, das gefällt mir besser. Viel schöner.
Zehn Stück 0,5
reicht. Achso, das
stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Ja, hast recht.
Das waren...
Naja.
Aber stimmt. Ja.
10G?
Vielleicht sollte man das doch machen, weil ich meine, ich habe
einen 10G-Switch.
Und ich verwende ja auch bei einigen Sachen 10G.
Vielleicht ist das auch nicht so
verkehrt. Macht das auch
10G? Ich meine, ich weiß, ich müsste
es eigentlich wissen, aber ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist schon viel zu
lang her.
Machen die auch 10G?
Cute Chat. Big Brain Chat.
Ich glaube nur 6A.
Der lernt das gerade.
Da musst du das wissen.
Warum jetzt für ein paar Cent das Geld?
Eigentlich hast du recht, ja.
Eigentlich hast du recht. Scheiß drauf.
Orange.
Blau. Gelb.
Das kostet zehn Stück, aber schon 18 Euro.
Bam.
Da müsste ich ja, wenn ich da von jedem...
Okay, ich kaufe von jedem. Fünf.
Fünf.
Und fünf.
Drei.
Nee, da kaufe ich bei Amazon. Fertig.
So, easy. Zack.
Was?
Warum soll ich für zehn Netzwerkkabeln eine Versicherung
bestellen?
Porgas.
Sehr gut.
So, reicht.
Genug davon.
Da haben wir auch bestellt.
Ich muss nochmal in meine Einkaufsliste für China-Kram
gucken.
Wenn wir jetzt wirklich alles haben.
Bunte Netzwerkkabel haben wir.
Air-Quality-Sensor lassen wir erstmal bleiben.
Relays haben wir.
Das ist so ein
12 Volt AC
auf Dings haben wir auch.
Ich habe mir
geschrieben, ich brauche Unterhosen, aber ich kaufe keine Unterhosen
bei AliExpress.
Mal gucken, was es da gibt.
Warte mal. Unterhosen Herren.
Ah.
Dann sehe ich,
dann sehe ich auch so aus, wenn ich das...
Was ist das?
What the fuck?
Was sehe ich da?
Ist das die
Pedobear-Unterhose oder was?
Oh Mann.
Der Tainzer verschenkt noch
mehr Abos.
WTF, jetzt geht es hier ab.
Elf Stück hat er verschenkt.
Und zwar an den Brian114
gibt es noch ein Stufe 1 Abo.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay.
Ich weiß...
Das ist glaube ich nicht die Unterhose,
die ich mir jetzt
heute bestelle.
Was sind das für Bilder?
Vor allem, was haben die alles
für Riesensalami da immer in den Bildern?
Vielleicht ist das
extra so fotografiert,
dass das immer
alles gut ausgefüllt ist, dass man
das Produkt besser erkennt, ja?
Sind eh nur Socken drin
wahrscheinlich, ja?
Und der Bauch ist Photoshop wahrscheinlich.
Ähm, Mann.
Nee, ich glaube, ich hole mir keine Unterhosen
bei AliExpress. Ich habe mir noch nie
Klamotten bei AliExpress geholt, noch nie.
Und eigentlich will ich mir auch keine Klamotten bei AliExpress
holen, weil ähm...
Ah, excellent.
Da sind Socken drin.
Garantiert sind da Socken drin.
Das sieht nicht natürlich aus, was sie da reingestopft haben.
Ähm...
Zumindest ich habe...
Ich denke, gerade bei Unterwäsche bei AliExpress,
so ähnlich, wie warum ich bei
Kick keine Unterwäsche kaufen würde,
ähm, wer weiß, was da drin ist. Nicht, dass man
da noch Ausschläge kriegt.
Die gleiche Geld, die bessere
Qualität. Ah, erst mal
eine russische, erst mal eine russische
Commodore-Mütze.
Die ist natürlich für die Unterhose
absolut essentiell.
Warum hat der eine Mütze auf? Vor allem,
guckt euch mal den Stern an, der sieht so aus, das fällt da schon
gleich wieder ab. Gut, nee, nee, nee,
wir kaufen keine Unterhose bei AliExpress, machen wir nicht.
Ich muss mir auch keine Unterhose
im Stream kaufen. Ich habe bloß auf meiner
Einkaufsliste stehen, ich brauche wieder ein paar Unterhosen.
Das kaufen wir hier nicht jetzt.
Ich wollte euch noch was zeigen,
und zwar
das Beste, die besten Tools,
die habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Ist das nicht die,
ist das nicht die aus, aus, aus,
ähm, Dings hier, wie heißt das, Baby Driver?
Ich gucke nicht
viele Filme, aber den fand ich eigentlich ganz,
ganz, ganz nett.
Das ist die doch, oder?
Ist die das?
Zeigt mal da mal irgendein Bild von.
Das ist die.
Die hier ist das, glaube ich, ne?
Ja, das ist die!
Ich wusste doch, dass ich die schon mal irgendwo gesehen habe, die da, die da.
Baby Driver ist ein super
Film, sagt PCLos. Ja, ich fand den auch gut.
Ich fand den, ich sag mal so, das letzte Viertel
war irgendwie dann so
komisch irgendwie, ähm,
aber an sich war es ein echt cooler Film.
Ja, äh,
was liegt denn heute schon im Warenkorb? Oh,
viel, ähm, also kann ich
dir zeigen, aktuell bei Amazon haben wir
Netzwerkkabel, äh, wasserdichte Steckdosen,
Spannungswandler
und Raspberry Pi Gehäuse.
Bei Pimoroni haben wir, äh,
Kamerakabel, ein Raspberry Pi 4,
noch einen, noch einen zweiten,
äh, einen Adapter von der
Raspberry Zero Kamera auf die große
Kamera und drei Raspberry
Pi Zero Kameras.
Äh, und bei AliExpress
haben wir keine Unterhosen, sondern
...
zehn, äh,
zehn, zwölf, beziehungsweise
24 Volt zu 5 Volt USB
Adapter,
sechs, äh,
5 Volt Relays, also
zum, 5 Volt zum Schalten und,
und was auch immer,
dann da drüber und zehn
96 Zoll
OLED Displays.
Richtig
Fortschritt im Vergleich zu gestern, gar nicht.
Das stimmt. Oh, der, der
Labor Day, was hat, was hat denn Banggood?
Äh, 0,6, äh,
0,96 Zoll. Habe ich gesagt
96 Zoll? Haha.
Excellent. Das, also,
das könnten mir doch nicht mal die Chinesen
96 Zoll verkaufen.
Moment, das haben wir doch gestern. Genau das gleiche
gab's doch, genau das gleiche
gab's doch schon gestern.
Inklusive diesen komischen,
äh, M, M,
Mask de Protection.
Mask, Mask de
Protection.
Hat AliExpress auch Labor Day?
So war nach Huge USB.
Den Kopf frei bekommen.
Was
gibt's denn da?
Ist dieselbe Schauspieler, ja.
Das sah ja auch echt ähnlich.
Ich hol mir einen neuen Raspberry Pi 4,
noch einen zweiten Raspberry Pi 4, ja.
Dass ich im Zweifelsfall noch einen Ersatz hab, falls ich
einen kaputt mach. Also,
Haushalts, ah, natürlich,
elektrische Zahnbürstenköpfe
sorgen immer dafür, dass ich den Kopf
frei kriege. Was auch immer
das eine mit der anderen zu tun hat.
Ähm.
Große Rabatte auf den Ausverkauf.
Ja.
Diese komische Brille haben wir gestern
mal bei Banggood auch gesehen.
Bis zu 91% Rabatt
Fake-Gold-Uhren, die kein Mensch
braucht.
Wer braucht, wer braucht
Uhren und dann vor allem noch so die Oldschool
Variante an Uhren?
Das ist, das ist ja komplett überflüssig
overrated. Das haben bloß noch
Stonksleute am Arm,
die zeigen wollen, wie geil sie sind.
Nailart und
Nee, nicht wirklich Haushaltsgeräte.
Achso, irgendjemand hat, er hat
ähm, empfohlen
Oh, der Montana Black, ja, das stimmt.
Weil ich auf der Arbeit auch einen Kollegen hab,
der hat auch sein
Geld in Rolex-Uhren angelegt.
Und der hat auch manchmal eine an.
Also, insofern, das kommt schon auch vor, aber
das kann man ja nicht vergleichen mit einer
AliExpress Fake-Gold-Uhr.
Oldschool-Uhren sind heutzutage
ziemlich hip. Aha.
Was ich für einen
Staubsauger-Roboter empfehlen kann,
hab ich ja schon oft gesagt, nämlich
den hier, genau den.
Allerdings, bisschen teuer ist er gerade.
Ich würde gucken, dass ich den für unter 300 Euro krieg.
Den Roborock S50
beziehungsweise den Roborock S5,
das ist der gleiche, mit Custom-Fairware.
Robocock.
Der Chat wieder.
Oh, Salami.
Was ist das?
Mini-Handheizung.
Gott, es gibt so viel Krempel.
Das ist zum Beispiel was,
das würde ich
nicht unbedingt
verwenden.
Also, ich hab ne Abneigung gegen
AliExpress-Geräte, die man
an die Steckdose stecken muss.
Also so richtig 230 Volt in die Steckdose.
Das ist Monka Smoke.
Wieso Custom-Fairware?
Räume?
Ja, ganz einfach.
Custom-Fairware auf dem Grund, dass ich
nicht abhängig bin von der China-Cloud,
dass mein Staubsauger funktioniert.
Erstmal PC-Lens-Teile bei AliExpress
kaufen. Ja, genau. Das sind so Dinger,
die mach ich. Ich wollte euch übrigens mal was zeigen.
Also, ich hab mir letztens,
ja, das ist schon ein bisschen her,
hab ich auch auf Twitter gepostet.
Ich hab mir ein bisschen Werkzeugnachschub gekauft
und eine Sache wollt ich euch mal, ganz ohne
Ref-Link, einfach nur so, weil
ich das richtig gut finde,
jetzt auch, nachdem ich es ein paar Mal verwendet hab,
wollte ich euch noch mal zeigen, nämlich das Ding.
Cool.
Das da.
Das Ding ist wirklich super. Oh, guck mal,
den gibt's auch in Blau.
Red Bull Racing.
Der gleiche Crap.
Das Ding ist wirklich
absolut
top.
Das ist richtig geil.
Also, ich hatte selten,
also ich hab mir selten ein Werkzeug
gekauft bisher, wo ich gesagt wär,
das ist so praktisch und so angenehm
in der Benutzung wie das.
Ähm, im Endeffekt
kriegt man, und wie gesagt, kein Ref-Link
oder so, einfach nur, weil ich es wirklich gut finde,
ähm, man kriegt, das ist ziemlich
klein, das ist ungefähr so groß wie zwei
Computermäuse nebeneinander,
ähm,
und, ähm,
das ist jetzt natürlich nix,
womit man einen Autoreifen anzieht
oder so, ja, oder,
oder irgendwelche,
fetten Dinger rein- und rausschraubte.
Das ist schon stabil,
also man kann damit ohne Probleme mal
nen Schrank zusammenbauen, und letztens
haben wir nen, so nen, so nen aus dänischen
Bettenlager, so nen Stuhl zusammengebaut,
das funktioniert
ohne Probleme, aber das so für die
Heavy, wie sagt man so, für die Heavy-Duty-Arbeiten ist
das jetzt nix.
Ähm,
zumindest hab ich dafür noch nicht ausprobiert, aber
dafür hat man glaub ich auch gar nicht genug Kraft damit.
Aber es ist wirklich qualitativ super Zeug,
und man hat alles dabei, was man so für das
für den Kram im Haushalt braucht.
Ähm, die Anwendung ist auch
richtig praktisch, äh,
es kommt hier, es kommt eigentlich zusammen,
genau, so,
so, so kommt das Ganze,
ist, ist ziemlich kompakt, ist auch, ist auch wirklich
schwer, und, äh,
hat ein gewisses Gewicht, also das fühlt sich nicht
billig an, man sieht's ja auch hier, das ist bloß
irgendwie 17, 17 cm lang,
und was man mitkriegt ist,
man kann das dann so ausklappen,
man macht hier neben diesen Wer,
Werra-Knopf hoch,
und dann klappt das vorne so aus,
was man kriegt ist, man kriegt, ähm,
Torx,
man kriegt diese
Security Torx, die mit dem Loch drin, ich weiß gar nicht,
was das, was, wie die, wie heißen diese
Security Torx Dinge, heißen die Security Torx?
Wohnst du eigentlich allein im Haus?
Nee, nee, nee, das Haus ist ja auch
gar nicht mir.
Irgendwann vielleicht mal.
Ähm,
guck mal, der Sebarro, wie der
Sebarro einfach mal einen Rev-Link generiert
hat für mich.
So, und, also wie gesagt, man kriegt Torx,
man kriegt Security Torx, man kriegt die normalen
Philips, ähm,
Kreuzschlitz-Dinger,
man kriegt, für was sind diese PZ-Dinger
nochmal, die habe ich glaube ich bis jetzt noch nicht verwendet,
ähm,
und man kriegt auch noch einen geraden
Schrauber,
Bit-Einsatz.
Dazu kriegt man noch ein paar Zwischenteile,
die man mit den anderen Sachen verwenden kann,
also sprich, äh, dass man hier die Nüsse draufstecken kann,
die haben diese,
die haben diese Wera, Wera-Färbung,
die ich bis heute nicht gecheckt habe,
ähm,
Wera hat ja irgendwie immer
an der gleichen Werkzeuggröße, so die gleiche
Färbung, blick ich nicht durch, was die
für eine Farbe irgendwo dran haben, aber
es sind so die Standard, die Standard-normalen
Größen, das sind übrigens keine Inches oder so,
das sind EU, EU-Maße.
So, und, dass
das, was das Ganze nochmal richtig gut
gemacht ist, erstens, dass das ziemlich komplett ist,
und man eigentlich für alle Schraubbelange
im Haushalt komplett versorgt ist damit,
ähm, das, was es richtig gut
macht, ist, man hat einmal hier oben noch
den Aufsatz, den, ähm,
den Bit-Halter,
hier oben rechts das Ding,
den, den, der passt auch bei anderen Wera-Sachen,
hier oben rechts den Bit-Halter,
den braucht man nicht unbedingt, man kann
die Bits, man kann die Bits auch so direkt
reinstecken, aber mit dem Bit-Halter
ist das, hat man ein bisschen, bisschen längeren
Schaft und, ähm,
es ist, es ist angenehmer,
und was cool dabei ist, ist so eine Mini-Ratsche
dabei, oder Knarre,
je nachdem, wie man, wie man, wie man das nennen mag,
ist so eine, so eine Mini-Knarre
dabei, hier, und die ist,
die sieht
klein und, und, äh,
unhandlich und eklig
aus, aber für so
Sachen, wie man Stuhl zusammenschrauben aus
dem, aus dem Ikea, aus dem Ikea,
da hat man ja überall so diese komischen Holzstifte,
wenn man was Kleines zusammenschrauben muss,
beispielsweise an der Waschmaschine musste ich letztens
den, den, den, den Dreckauffangbehälter
rausschrauben, und
ich sag euch, das war, da ist kein Drehmomentschlüssel
dabei, nein, Quatsch, so ein kleines Zeug
da, ähm,
da musstest du den Kopf,
Kopf in die Waschmaschine reinmachen,
und dann innen drinnen,
im, in, in der, in der Drommel
was abschrauben für den Dreckbehälter,
und da war ich wirklich froh,
dass ich, dass ich die, dass ich die Knarre hier
am Start hatte, denn mit
so einem normalen Schraubendreher kriegst du Anfälle,
und den
hast du einfach draufgesetzt,
hast du hier so einen, so einen normalen Kreuzschlitz
draufgemacht, draufgesetzt,
nächste Schraube ab, gut,
ausgeleert, Dings wieder drangemacht.
Also, wollt ihr euch bei der stellen,
ist wirklich super,
kann ich nur empfehlen, also
wer ein, ein Bitsortiment oder einfach,
einfach für den Haushalt was braucht,
mit dem er nahezu alles machen kann,
wo es ums Schrauben geht, sollte
sich das Ding hier kaufen, die 55 Euro
sind wirklich super angelegt.
So, und noch ein zweites Ding, was ich
auch ganz gut fand, was ich jetzt aber nicht
äh, sage, also nicht in dem
Umfang, wo ich sagen würde, kauft euch das,
ähm, da bringt euch immer was, ich
hab mir noch so einen Vera Maintenance
Kit gekauft,
einfach, dass man auch mal ein paar richtige
Schraubendreher hat.
Das ist auch cool, vor allem diese Zyklop,
Zyklop, ähm, Schraube
Knarre ist, ist auch sehr nice.
Das ist aber eher, eher was bisschen
spezielleres, ähm,
aber ist auch wirklich gut verarbeitet und,
und top.
Das ist nicht so das, das andere würde ich euch,
das, das Tool Check,
das Ding kann ich euch wirklich,
und jetzt auch sogar mit RevLink,
uneingeschränkt empfehlen.
Ist wirklich super das Teil.
Und ihr seht's ja auch hier im Chat, ähm,
wir haben auch ein paar Leute, die das schon haben und die sagen auch alles
toll.
Da merkt man, wo das YouTube Money steckt.
Das YouTube Money steckt vor allem grad nirgendwo,
weil es kaum YouTube Money gibt.
Leute, ich hab einen neuen Vertrag gekriegt,
von meinem,
von meinem Netzwerk. Ist natürlich super,
geheim und ich darf nix dazu erzählen.
Deswegen erzähl ich jetzt auch nix, was da genau drinsteht.
Aber, eine Sache kann ich euch erzählen.
Die haben irgendwie
erweitert,
für was sie zuständig
sein wollen.
Und damit bin ich nicht so ganz einverstanden.
Das muss ich, das muss ich denen morgen mal schon beibringen.
Ähm,
bisher bin ich da nämlich nur mit meinem
YouTube Channel.
Und in der Vertragserweiterung
steht drinne, ich krieg jetzt ein paar mehr Prozent,
das ist super.
Ich mach nix auf YouTube,
wozu brauch ich ein paar Prozent mehr?
Da steht jetzt auf einmal auch mein Twitter
und mein Twitch Channel mit drinne.
Wo sie für zuständig sind.
Und da muss ich mal sagen, da bin ich,
Twitter, mein, Twitter, aber Twitch
garantiert nicht.
Auf Twitch mach ich was ich will.
Das hat mit meinem YouTube Zeug überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Auf meinem Twitch Channel
kriegt mein Netzwerk keinen Zugriff.
Kannste vergessen. Gibt's nicht.
Das kündige ich lieber, bevor ich
Leuten Zugriff auf meinen Twitch Channel gebe.
Könnte ich vergessen.
2020 immer noch in einem Netzwerk?
Ja, vielleicht nicht mehr lange.
Wofür nutzt du das Netzwerk?
Tja, das ist ne berechtigte Frage.
Eigentlich so ne wirkliche Daseinsberechtigung haben sie nicht.
Easy.
Ich kann mich noch an Zeiten erinnern, wo du gesagt hast,
du trittst niemals einem Netzwerk bei.
Ja, manche Sachen sind
schneller, äh, outdated
als man so denkt.
So.
Oh Leute, es ist 22 Uhr.
Ich muss gleich auf.
Haben wir alles bestellt?
Sieht so aus.
Ich hab alles, außer Unterhosen.
Außer Unterhosen haben wir alles bestellt.
Ähm,
ach ja, was ich nochmal bei AliExpress gucken wollte
ist, ich will mir
keinen kaufen, aber was kostet denn so
ein TS100 Lötkolben?
Die Dinger
sind ja voll angesagt zur Zeit.
Das ist so ein Mini,
teilweise sogar per USB ladbarer
äh, per USB betreibbarer Lötkolben.
Braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Ist eigentlich total überflüssig,
aber ich wollte mal gucken, was der Kram kostet.
TS80 ist der mit dem USB.
Stimmt auch.
Du hast Recht.
Nicht TS100.
Der ist ja viel zu teuer.
Warum soll ich mir den denn kaufen?
Weil er schon klein ist und Customfirma draufgegangen.
Ist eigentlich viel zu teuer, oder?
Weil ich mein, ich krieg ne richtig
gute Lötstation für 150 Euro.
Oder für 200
ne noch bessere.
Warum soll ich mir dann sowas kaufen für 80?
Ich weiß nicht.
Habt ihr eigentlich gelesen?
OpenOffice
oder besser gesagt LibreOffice
heißt der Kram, ja?
Die haben jetzt den Support
für Flash eingestellt.
Mocker es.
Ich wusste gar nicht, bis zu der Newsmeldung
dass die überhaupt jemals Flash unterstützt haben.
Warum braucht man denn ein Office-Programm?
Ihr wisst, ich verwende eh keinerlei Office-Programme.
Seht ihr, Leute?
Kein Word drauf, kein Excel drauf, nix.
Ich hab kein Office.
Bei mir kommt Office nicht auf den Rechner.
Ich versteh nicht, wozu man da Flash braucht.
Das sieht aus wie was für ein Zahnarzt.
Aber es sind anscheinend Lötkolben-Spitzen.
Könnte was vom Zahnarzt sein.
Kannst du eine Lötstation bis 60 empfehlen?
Nee, ich hab da auch nicht so viel Erfahrung.
Also ich hatte da auch noch nicht so viele verschiedene Lötstationen.
Ich hab eigentlich außer einem Billig-Lötkolben
bisher nur die hier mir geholt.
Nach langem Überlegen hab ich mir nur die hier geholt.
nach langem Überlegen hab ich mir nur die hier geholt.
Und ich weiß nur, dass die ziemlich gut ist, weil die hab ich.
Und auch die, weil das die kleinere Variante davon ist,
die ist auch relativ gut.
Aber für 60 Euro, keine Ahnung.
So, ich glaube wir haben wirklich alles bestellt.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ich glaub's nicht, wir haben mal wirklich einen Stream.
Wir haben mal wirklich in dem Stream was fertig gekriegt.
Wahnsinn. Oh, ich hab was gesehen.
Ande hat resubscribed für 6 Monate.
Big Brain Subscriber.
Oh, ich muss mal meinen Text
zu Speech versuchen lassen, Big Brain zu sagen.
Mal gucken, was es dann macht.
In der Hoffnung, es kackt jetzt nicht ab.
Big Brain.
mussste mal kobber tranquil doesn't explain
pirale
Nee, das müssen wir anders sagen.
Nee.
Der Cesaro kennt sich aus.
Ah,
Gudeweg, schaue deine Video schon seit 6-7 Jahren
und wusste bis vor Kurzem gar nicht, dass du streamst.
Na ja, ich
stream schon seit 2 Jahren jetzt, allerdings
andere Sachen, als ich auf
YouTube mache.
Und das machen wir auch nicht oft. Ich versuche
bloß gerade meine Text-to-Speech mal
das Wort Big Brain zu entlocken.
Ah, das ist gut. Das ist,
das ist, das gefällt mir schon besser.
Ja, das ist gut. Das lassen wir.
Das ist gut.
Hast du diese, die habe ich
selbst gebastelt, ja.
Und die, guck mal, wie, guck mal, guck mal,
wie advanced die ist. Die kann sogar
GIF-Animationen mit Sounds abspielen.
Highly
sophisticated, ja.
Mit Flash-Support, das fehlt noch.
Ja, mit Flash-Support.
Wenn der Browser Flash kann, kann die wahrscheinlich sogar Flash.
Ist in deinem Git-Repo.
Eine uralte
Version ist in meinem Git-Repo, die damit überhaupt nichts mehr
zu tun hat.
Oh, oh mein Gott.
So, alles klar. Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid,
Leute. Ich muss pennen. Ich muss morgen noch
einen Tag Homeoffice machen. Dann ist die Woche
gelaufen. Ich hoffe, euch hat
der Stream gefallen. Ich muss jetzt gucken, wie ich das hier
mache, dass ich...
die...
Bestellungen behalte.
Ich speichere einfach meine
Session und bestelle
den Kram dann, wenn ich off bin.
Leute, es hat kaum
geleckt. Sehr schön.
Ähm...
Brauchen wir noch Outro-Musik? Ich glaube,
wir brauchen noch Outro-Musik, oder?
Wir brauchen noch Outro-Musik.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns vielleicht
morgen. Mal gucken. Bin mir noch nicht
ganz sicher. Bis
denn. See you.
Outro-Musik